all right you're all set to
go thank you Christina good morning
everyone to members of CNA committee
morning to everyone who
viewing I will uh start off by reading
this lengthy chairman
script as chair of the house environment
and agricultureal committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
the governor's emergency order order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a committee or
meeting and please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and legis select
legislative staff of the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting notice complies with house
rules and RSA
91a anyone who's having a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 27136 600 or email
HCS
l.st new hampshire.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled Christina Dyer
committee researcher will be the staff
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote to start the
meeting by taking a roll call of
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state whether there
was anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know
law I will ask the clerk to please call
the
role here
sorry
and
J pres in the committee Room St here in
alone
present in um my uh study in do New
Hampshire there are other people in h in
repres
represent I'm present and I'm alone at
home in Nashville New Hampshire
repr B I'm pres in the Comm room with
members uh I'm present alone in my
Amherst present I'm here in uh my house
Kean
Highlands present in my home office in
francistown New Hampshire my husband is
you
uh preson I'm here my house in Milford
alone
here I am present and I am in the
committee room with various members of
the committee we did have rep s born
now representative sandborn seems uh
Representatives uh Kaplan uh notified me
that he won't be uh able to join us
until about
ahead did you have a
question yeah I'm sorry I I forgot to
mention I'm in my my uh office which is
an open laboratory and uh there'll be
people coming and going throughout the
representative okay we uh have some
bills this morning and we're also going
to do some exact session in amongst the
bills as we have time I'll remind
everyone that in order to participate in
the vote you have to have your camera on
so that I can verify that it is you
voting
if anyone is having any issues or
concerns with that please let us know
ASAP so we can try and find a way to
rectify that thank
you all right uh our first bill is going
to be House Bill 250 which I am the
sponsor so I'm going to turn the meeting
over to Vice chairman
you
[Music]
everybody so this morning's hearing we
him thank you
m Mee for the record is represented
250 some changes in theend
definition updated in back in
2018 have amendment
that
should the were supposed to bring them
down I have the incorrect Amendment here
one minor change so if you don't have
the correct there I'll give you this one
change does anybody have cop
access
um just one quick question are we
talking about Amendment
196 so I give these anyone in I'll just
corre the error there
down
it is's one
[Music]
address happens se one is making
Amendment to the definition that changed
50 down to
25 that has become problem
many of
get it's very low for them to achieve so
what this amendment proposes to do is
leave that number up to 30 for dos this
is the one difference
between
35 orig had moved it 30 gas I have to
talk with some some members that are in
the F line breeding industry
excuse me Mr chair we're not able to
hear you very
well that's much better thank you I'm
sorry about that so the uh the 30 dogs
we move the number up to 30 dogs and we
move the Caps up to
35 and then
uh the next part that is changed in that
the uh that the amendment would change
is moving the reporting date from
January 1 to December 31st excuse me
yeah the transfer date from January 1 to
December 31st and it would keep the
registration date at the current uh July
1 to June 30th this was done on the
request of the commissioner because he's
having uh issues with those two dates
happening at the same time so he is
going to come on and testify after me
and I'll let him discuss uh the
reasoning for
that the second part of the bill deals
with an exemption that would allow
a breeder who has not qualified to be a
pet vendor for the last four 12 months
periods or four years to apply for an
exemption if they found themselves in a
situation where they had a two letters
that say they had eight animals or nine
animals and then all of a sudden the
third litter they were breeding they
thought they'd be safely under the
number and all of a sudden they have a a
a litter of 15 you know types of things
do happen and so this would give them an
opportunity to apply for an exemption
because theoretically what would happen
is if they exceed that threshold they
would then have to qualify as a pet
vendor and they're looking to transfer
these animals you know these dogs per
say let's use that for an example in
roughly 8 to 10 weeks and it would be
near impossible for them to get through
all the Hoops to become a pet V this
would allow them an opportunity to go to
the commissioner and ask for this
exemption and say uh you know we we have
this situ situation that occurred and we
realize we're going to be over and and
we meet the criteria there's two
specific criteria and I'll read uh
number one person has transferred fewer
than 30 dogs or 35 cats annually in the
previous 412 months period beginning
January 1 through December
31st the second is the person has not
been required to register as a pet
vendor in the previous 4 12 months
period beginning January 1 through the
following
uh December
31st so those are important those are
two important points because this is a
pretty narrow exemption and and they
have to be make sure that they have not
exceeded you know and been qualified to
be a pet fendor or they would not be
able to seek this
exemption the uh next thing that happens
is the commissioner should make a
determination on such exemption within
15 days of its submission such such
exemption shall expire on December 3rd
first fing its issuance again another
point this isn't allowed to be a is
meant to be a management tool for a
breeder it's meant to if they get into a
situation that they have found
themselves in where they had this
exceptionally High litter that they
could apply for this once every four
years and by expiring it does not allow
them to continue on into the next year
they go back to the original
WS Point uh C is a person exempt from
lure as a pet vendor under this
paragraph May transfer no more than 15
dogs or 15 cats in addition to the 30
dog or 35 cat women in sub paragraph a
within the period and his or her
exemption is valid so we've not only
given very narrow reasons of you know
we've narrowed the exceptions as to why
they can get I mean the criteria why
they can get the exception there was
also a threshold limit on the top that
exceed the last portion action three of
the bill is dealing with a zoning issue
that has occurred during the uh language
that was put in in the
[Music]
18 but so one of the things that's
occurring is there was a zoning
requirement that was placed in
previously to that zoning requirement
any animals uh any pet vendor that was
uh transferring 50 or more animals had
had to apply comply with some zoning
this moved it down to 25 what this did
is it really scooped into that net a a
bunch of very small breeders that now
all of a sudden are faced with having to
go to their zoning boards and make sure
that they are in compliance with zoning
to have that you know breeding three
letters that many of them do right in
their own home and so that became
problematic so what action three of this
bill would do was it would just simply
move that number back to the 50 trans of
dogs or cats or ferrets or birds in
order to comply with the zoning
requirements this would put it back to
where they were prior to 2018 as far as
just as far as the zoning portion
home if they uh you know they still
would have to try to be a pet vendor at
30 dogs or 35 cats but they wouldn't
trigger the zoning thing until they get
up to 50 so that so what that does is it
allows these home breeders who are very
small in nature and again often doing
this in their home would allow them not
to have have to get into that whole
zoning nightmare that some of them have
been really
struggling I think that're pretty well
describes what's going on uh what the
bill does uh guess I will open up to
questions Madam P if there are any from
the
committee I have a question from
representative Murray
yep hi thank you um sh um
chairwoman um thank you for taking my
question representative Pearl I did have
a question on page two line two of the
amendment um it reads that such an
exemption shall expire on the December
31st following its issuance just a small
grammatical thing is that how it is
read I'm sorry can you speak louder yeah
yes I was saying on page two line two of
the amendment it reads such an exemption
Sal it shall expire on the December 31st
following the issuance and I was just
curious if that's how it intended to
something I guess it it uh could be
changed I mean it it may be technically
grammatic wrong but that is the way that
OSS recommended agree but I will
you let see who
[Music]
else oh I'm sorry um representative Bal
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um do you know
whether anyone has gone over the2 or
25 yes I would ask you to direct that
question to the commission when he
testifies I believe so but he'll have
would if that is the case would this not
help them for another four years then or
language
so if this passes as written if they've
had to qualify or they have been
registered as a pet vendor then they
will have four years before they seek
the
exemption oh I'm sorry representative H
question
the new amendment is here that was the
one change it's the original Amendment
error
Dy uh yes I just want to make the
comment that when the speakers in the
committee room move even slightly away
from the
microphone uh we can't hear you you
become very garbled so although I could
understand representative Pearl's
answers I couldn't understand the
question so um I don't know if that if
there's a way to rectify it but from my
perspective it appears that when you
move your face away from the
microphone uh it becomes
garbled thank you representative we've
got uh multi- Correctional mics for the
remainder of the folks here and we'll
have to have them move closer to them
when they're asking questions thank you
that representative comp thank
you is it possible for repres
to
question sure representative Balden '
been requested to ask your question
call um so my questions were um do you
know whether anyone has gone over the 25
dogs since these numbers went from 50 to
25 and the follow question was would
this bill therefore enough help them for
another four years then would there be a
grand was everybody able to hear that
did answer that again representative
Pearl sure if you'd like me
to so I on the first part of the
question I'd asked that he defer that to
the commissioner as he's going to
testify next and he'll have better info
on that than I do and the second part of
the question is uh as written if the uh
person seeking exception had
um qualified to be a pet vendor or
registered to be a pet limited then it
would be four years before they could
exception thank you very much um now I
believe that um commissioner Jasper has
questions
so waiting to be unmuted all right can
you hear me now yes good morning thank
you sorry for that delay this is a
strange new world to me as I'm sure it
is to all of you as
well um so the couple questions here um
that I've heard in the first is I don't
actually know how many new pet vendors
we have
registered
uh
yes wait a minute I've got an email back
from the state
veterinarian um and if you give me a
moment to get to my email I can give you
question
yeah oh sorry about
that when the threshold was 50
um we had five about five license
breeders currently we have 15 licensed
breeders this is obviously just uh for
dogs we don't have total number of pet
vendors but obviously the number has
gone up for breeders
substantially uh relative to the the
date difference here we we actually
realized IED in the process uh last year
that having both dates be um running
from January or rather from uh July 1st
through June 30th created a problem for
us in that if somebody was to be
licensed we might not have the complete
uh data Available To Us by the licensing
date and um because we do have a small
staff it also created some problems
without the database particularly of
trying to bring all those numbers
together and and see where we were so
this gives us that six-month window
which makes a lot of sense um to us to
to be able to um look forward as we move
into the licensing
year uh not sure if I recall any other
questions in there but I'll be glad to
have
see any questions from the
comme representative
viby yes um I was wondering if uh the
fact that the submission of the um uh
Health certificates is currently listed
as optional as creating an impediment to
knowing who you should actually be
licensing well obviously that's not the
best um way to do we currently request
them if we think there may be um
somebody who's transferring more
than uh than the limit however the
problem as you learned last week um is
that we don't have the ability to take
those 880,000 documents and and properly
um deal with them anyhow and so you know
until we have the database up and
running um you know there's just no way
we're going to catch them all I when the
number of uh animals increased a couple
of years ago we informed the house and
the Senate that uh you know we would not
be able to to comply with this at 100%
we're doing the best that we can we only
received one new employee and um we're
we're putting well more than one
full-time position into this effort
right now as it is so as Dr Crawford
told you last week you know it's sort of
what what is the priority of of the day
so um you know we the
legislature and put the cart before the
horse if you will we're going to
continue to try to get that horse back
in front of the cart but it is going to
be a number of years before the the
horse is in front of the cart um so
we're doing the best we can but we are
not going to catch
everybody uh it's going to be somewhat
by happens sometimes it's people
reporting that um people are trans
transferring animals we didn't know
about we look into it sometimes it's
local law
enforcement um and sometimes we happen
to to catch them because a veterinarian
may send in a number of um certificates
but you know it's it's sort of just a a
crapshoot right now and it will continue
to be in all frankness I mean we just do
not have the
Personnel um to be able to to deal with
this and so you know the going from 25
um back up to 30 probably won't make
much difference for us will certainly
make a difference for some people but um
I don't know if it'll take any of those
readers out of the U out of the
definition right now or not but um
you know we're constantly dealing with
issues this morning I
just um reviewed two letters of fines
going out to two different uh pet
vendors one because hasn't bothered to
uh renew his license and the other um
for you know essentially health issues
within the store and sanitary issues and
so those are things we're we're
constantly trying to deal with but not
going to uh not going to get there
anytime
sure my question is for commissioner
Jasper with the six months with that six
Monon window um with a person that
qualifies by December
31st but would they not get licensed
1st you know I don't know if Dr Crawford
is on or not um I think that anybody can
get licensed at any time during the
licensing period their license would
then get get renewed I believe on July
31st on July 1st so um I don't I don't
think that creates any any type of a a
problem I think we license people as as
they ask to be licensed we don't make
somebody came in in August we wouldn't
say too bad you've missed the window I
think it would just be a matter of their
license would run for you know 10 or 11
months instead of a full year on that
first
year thank you commissioner Jasper
um Mr Crawford is on would you like him
to answer that at this time I would like
him to just to make sure that I didn't
give you some bad information okay go
ahead Mr C Dr C I'm sorry no worry can
me can I got a couple thumbs up um
commissioner's correct I get sort of a
yes the commissioner is correct
uh you can get license at any point
during the year you don't have to wait
to an for a new
license I'm sorry would you repeat that
we didn't hear that well sure I'm trying
to get closer to my my computer here um
so the commissioner was correct you can
get Li anyone can get licensed at any
point during the licensing year uh
there's not an obligation and we don't
make people wait until a new licensing
year to get licensed so someone who
applied in December could get licensed
in December and then that license would
be good through the June 30th expiration
of that licensing
year thank you very much for
that
next I guess we have Angela Ferrari from
testify good
morning good morning can you hear me I
can hear you fine wonderful um hello
everybody and thank you for the time to
speak today my name is Angela Ferrari
and I am with the dog owners of the
Granite State and I just wanted to touch
on a few points um over this bill and I
want to thank representative Pearl for
doing a really great job explaining all
of the different aspects of the bill so
hopefully I can keep this nice and short
um as mentioned this bill is due to
legislation in 2019 that was passed
without getting to go through both the
house and the Senate um and it was put
into the budget so there was not a lot
of opportunity for public comment on
this bill and my group dog owners of the
granite state has always been very
opposed to the original version of the
bill um we feel hb250 takes steps in the
right direction to address many of the
issues um that we had with the original
Bill primarily it was the reduction in
the threshold by 50% from what was
originally in law prior to that 2019
bill um which which is a really a big
jump from being licensed for breeders of
dogs and cats um a little bit of history
on litter sizes for some of you who
maybe haven't um been on the committee
in Prior years um a dog can have
anywhere from one puppy to upwards of 12
being more consistent on the large end
but there have been cases of 15 to 20
puppies in the single Le litter so this
speaks a little bit to the exemption
that was mentioned where a breeder may
have a couple standard size litters
think that they have the ability to have
one more litter without going over that
have
hang
on I got cut off Midstream and getting
that
fixed oh sorry I think I got muted again
sorry um not sure what the last piece
you heard was but essentially I was just
saying that final litter could really
put them over the threshold and require
them to become licensed as a pet vendor
um there isn't necessarily anything
wrong wrong with becoming licensed as a
pet vendor but a lot of small hobby
breeders do try and avoid additional
fees such as licensing that would be
required um they are protective of their
homes and disease that can be brought in
by anyone from the outside coming in
such as during an
inspection um they also you know don't
like to be added to public lists where
animal rights activists could
potentially
um Target them for any reason and so
there's just some reasons that they like
to not become pet vendors commercial
breeders whatever it may be called it
isn't a business for the majority of
these people it's it's a hobby and a
passion um example for myself I do breed
doberman's but I have a full-time job
that's really just what I do on the
weekends and I show my dogs and things
like that so just a little bit of
background there um the exemption would
give the opportunity for that kind of
one fluke incident where a breeder does
go over the limit to get evaluated by
the Department of Agriculture so that
they can look to see no they haven't
gone over in the last four years they
really don't seem to be somebody that we
should force to become a pet vendor at
this time we'll grant them this
exemption for this one
year um there is a little bit of
confusion and I don't know maybe at the
end commissioner Jasper can comment on
this um regarding the timing I know we
talked about at any time you can submit
to become a pet vendor um if you are a
pet vendor and you're waiting to get a
renewal and they're counting through
December 31st there is a six-month
period where I guess you would still be
considered a pet vendor but you haven't
got your renewal yet and so just want to
clarify that there isn't any concern
with anyone not being able to continue
to transfer animals during that time um
so maybe at the end he can comment on
that going back to the points of the
bill uh with the increase in dogs and
cats to 30 and 35 as in the latest
Amendment um it's still a 35 to 40% drop
from the pre 2019 numbers but we feel is
a little bit more reasonable and gives a
little bit more flexibility for those
small hobby breeders to just have a
little bit of room before they do end up
becoming pet vendors which essentially
is a
commercial um
license the biggest part of this bill
that I really really like is the
adjustment to the municipal Zone in
Conformity requirements because that is
a really huge aspect to becoming a pet
vendor in current law even at um the 25
puppies for example you cannot become a
pet vendor without Municipal zoning
Conformity which requires you to
complete a form bring it to your town
likely you're going to have to go to a
town board meeting and essentially
you're asking to become a commercial
entity within your town and that may not
be approved in many towns not only that
the people your ab Butters around you
have to often provide approval as well
and when it sounds like you want to
become a pet vendor or a commercial
kennel type entity um that is very
concerning to a lot of people because it
sounds like you're going to have
hundreds of dogs barking and become
something that you're not when they
don't even realize that for many years
you've been practicing this hobby from
your home um your
residence so we have actually had a
number of people in our community who
have been unable to attain that zoning
Conformity from their town and that
makes them unable to obtain the pet
vendor license which means they're not
able to continue to have puppies to
transfer um and continue their hobby so
essentially
it really the license application really
is uh resulting in some violations of
due process for those who you know have
been doing this out of their residence
um All This Time by increasing the
threshold for the Zone in Conformity
back to our pre 20109 numbers of the 50
transfers it really just gives a little
bit of flexibility to those who want to
continue to operate out of their homes
and I want everyone to to keep in mind
that these puppies that are being raised
in homes and kittens as well those are
animals that are growing up in such a
wonderful environment who our New
Hampshire residents can buy to bring
into their homes and I don't think it's
something that we want to lose those are
really special breeders and
preservationists of breeds um who are
rais in puppies in that type of
environment versus those who are coming
from you know kennels and they're not
having that home experience so I think
it's really important that
we help those type of breeders continue
to do what they're doing so that we can
continue to have those Health tested
genetic tested uh working trait tested
animals available to our residents um
and not push them out of existence by
really tight laws so hb250 helps us go
in the right direction to fix some of
the problems that came up in
2019 um and last year this committee did
favorably vote ought to pass on a
similar version of this bill that just
wasn't able to make its way further due
to the covid pandemic so I hope you will
all consider doing that again this year
and I would be happy to take any
questions thank you you is Ferrari uh
and we have a question from
representative Bixby sure yes thank you
thank you madam chair for taking my
question thank you uh Miss Farrari um I
was wondering if you could explain why
transferring animals is important for a
breeder thank you for the question I
would be happy to um I'll use myself as
an example the reason that I even breed
any of my my dogs is because I'm trying
to always produce an animal Better Than
Better Health better temperament better
working ability for whatever it is that
I may be doing with my dogs um so that I
can continue to produce the Doberman for
the people who love that breed as much
as I do the other reason I do it is
because I do like to compete
um in confirmation shows with my dogs um
I have people who do agility scent work
different activities with their dogs um
and for me to be able
to use the creation from my breeding
program um in those shows is really
important to me and unfortunately I
can't keep every single puppy from every
litter because then we would have a
hoarding situation at my house house and
as much as I love every one of them I do
want to make sure that they end up in
fabulous homes and it is actually
another a really happy time um when I
get to see my puppies go off to their
new homes and the new families are just
ecstatic and the puppies are going to
deserve thank you thank you um and now I
I see uh commissioner Jasper you have
yes and and I'm going to start off by
apologizing to uh chairman Pearl I had
not seen his his Amendment although I
was aware of the issue relative to the
zoning and I understand the concern
there what I'm I'm going to suggest is
that I understand the issue for people
who are currently breeding but the way
the language is this would sort of
continue to to create a conflict perhaps
with local Zoning for people who are
coming into the
industry so I would like to suggest that
perhaps this should be a grandfathering
situation and for anybody who had
um been transferring animals and that's
evident through uh Health certificates
prior to the adoption of this to give
them the exemption but for people who
wanted to come online and start breeding
then I don't think they should have that
zoning um exemption it's going to create
you know a little bit more work for us
here but I but I think that that
conflict with local
zoning on a continuing basis need not
continue I also wanted to correct um Dr
Crawford had initially sent me email
saying 15 readers he corrected that
afterwards but before I
uh I didn't see it before I testified
and eight they're currently 18 breeders
licensed thank you
commissioner do we have any other
questions
from the uh committee or from any
attendees I'd like to ask
question I a question
Mr on on line number four it says
uh a vendor would be somebody that
transfers 30 or more dogs so the magic
number would be 29 if they hit 30 vendor
is that
question so the your question is at 30
and above they become a p vendor yes yes
questions represent
askor my question um it kind of relates
to the questions I was asking previously
and I'm thinking so that the Breeders
who got caught up in this whole 25
transfer issue can take advantage of the
exemption four years I'm wondering if
there's something we could do to take a
steep approach and implement it like U
maybe make it one 12 month period
affected immediately and then two 12
month periods affected in January 2022
2024 thank you for the question I'll
certainly consider that let me uh let me
think about that and and I discussed
with Dr Crawford and the commissioner
how much of a headache this would be for
them that that would be my my big
concern the more of this St approach
that you do I fully understand where
you're coming from with it I'm just not
positive that it would be able to be
implemented without a lot of headaches
so so let me have that conversation with
them this this bill won't be coming up
for EXA for a couple of weeks so we've
got a little bit of time we can make
tweaks to it as necessary thank you for
idea thank you representative Pearl and
thank you representative Balden uh do I
see any other comments or questions of
holes okay is that better there you are
okay okay sorry got to hit the button F
fast enough before it
disappears um well my name's Nancy
Holmes I'm here today from New Boston
New Hampshire and I've um already
written in and said I was in um support
of the the bill as amended but I find
I'm really confused on one issue um
because they've changed the exemption
year to run from January to December and
the license year runs from July to June
what year are you Exempted
commission sorry about that yes um you'd
be Exempted from the licensing year for
the licensing Year we're we're going
back um and in counting the previous
year but you would be Exempted for that
period of July 1st through June June
30th of the previous year or the current
year I mean the C previous year or the
next year I I I have a really I'm sorry
excuse me I I have a really hard time
with the the fact that you can't figure
out if you need to be licensed until
you've produced the puppies and so it's
really hard for me to understand which
year you're getting licensed for never
mind which year you'd get an exemption
for
let me let me try again if I may thank
you so in this let's pretend it's law
right now just so I get my ear
straight so we would now we're now in
January of
2021 we would know everyone in the state
theoretically who had health
certificates issued in calendar year 20
so that would tell us that all of those
licensed um
from July 1st 2021 through June 30th
2022 so that would give them and us
plenty of time to deal with the
exemption because at at that time some
point in January we would be able to
inform everyone that they would need to
be licensed in the coming July and if
they had a reason they wanted to be
exempt they would have time to make
their case submit the application for an
exemption we would be able to look at
that and make our
determination and exempt them at that
point or not exempt them for July 1st of
21 to June 30th of 22 so it actually
gives everybody a lot more time U makes
a lot more sense to do it that way than
minute okay I'm I'm sorry I I I just
must be really dense because I don't
follow this puppies are normally born
spring and fall so you're saying that
the number of puppies born between July
and December would require you to be
licensed um for that year but if you
didn't meet the criteria but you did
come spring now I'm I'm still I'm still
totally lost well I
I the number of puppies will be counted
from January
1st through December
31st okay and that will allow you to
look forward to see if you will need to
be licensed as of July 1st of the
following year okay so it gives you
plenty of time to get your ducks in a
row to be able to be licensed and we
will be particularly once we have the
database we'll be in a situation to let
everyone know hey in the coming months
you need to either apply for an
exemption or become a licensed pet
vendor um you know I think that makes
more sense than having everybody behind
the eightball including
us
okay thank you so much for the for the
explanation um it it sounds to me like
the licensing is based on past history
as opposed to current current year
breeding so you might end up being
licensed for a year in which you produce
no puppies at
all that is would be the purpose of
having the
exemption saying hey we went over but we
don't plan on having any in the coming
year and we wouldn't require somebody to
to be like Ed if they said we're not
going to be producing any puppies in
22 that's a perfectly reasonable ask at
that
point okay super thank you so much for
being patient with me I figure if I
didn't okay thank you Miss Holmes um I
have a question from representative
Balden thank you madam chair um this is
kind of a question for the commissioner
or really it's about the commissioner's
comment
sure thank you I'm looking at page two
line two where it states such extion
shall expire on the December 31st
following its issue from what I heard
you just say it sounds like this should
probably say um June 30th because that's
the licensing 12 month cycle July to
toct uh that's very Tech
technical so you you may well be
correct but I think I'd have to have
some more more discussions relative to
how that that would actually work
because
we're I think that may be referring to
the exemption being the number of
puppies
produced and if that's the case then or
number of animals if that that's case
then that that is correct because we're
we're looking at the
exemption for producing a number of
animals over the
limit for that 12month period so I think
that the
exemption would expire
then um but you know it is complicated
and have to have probably a little bit
deeper con ation about how that would
work we'll have to look at that and and
represent has a follow it's a follow
question for the chair um we're getting
into work session territory I'm
wondering we have a work session on this
bill I feel like there's a lot of
experts yes sure
chairman thank you representative we're
not able to have any work sessions this
spring because of that but I I think the
point you're making is very easily
correctable so we I think we could
probably deal with that any any
sidec thank you for bringing it up I I
point thank you for that
representative and representative P you
had okay thank you um so we're we're
over our time here
and believe we have everybody's
questions answered
and supp
testify
are oh yes um according to the blue
sheet we had five persons who supported
to
so we have um House Bill 249 an act
relative to animal shelter facilities
I'd like to open this hearing and have
representative Pearl
you morning thank you madam chair for
representative marac 26 representing DET
towns of Lowden Boston Canary Northfield
and Ward 3 of Franklin I'm also the
chair of the house CNA
committee so 249 is an act relative to
animal shelter
facilities this is a bill that we had
last year and uh the primary driver on
the bill we received it was to address
an issue that the shelter facilities
were having in the definition and that
is what the First Act of the bill does
is it adds the language or
to the bill to the current language
because the some of the shelters were
running into situations where they
didn't own their building and they
technically didn't comply with the
definition of animal shelter facility so
we're looking at the bill last term the
uh
committee looked to tighten up some
other areas of the uh the animal shelter
facility language which is in part two
relating to health certificates
so uh this language has been been
reviewed by the the shelters of New
Hampshire and they've been in agreement
there is one Amendment which is
amendment
that
available I need one okay all
right so that will come into play on the
second page of this bill so when
reviewing this language with the
shelters uh I'll go through the uh the
parts of it basically this takes some
language that was in rules and codifies
it which is uh on the back page but on
the on the section five A and B a
language that the committee the H Ena
committee reviewed last year and we just
wanted to add these in to tighten up uh
identifying characteristics that
shelters had to look for when they were
brought an animal in the whole goal was
to make sure that if the animal is lost
or stolen it ends up in a shelter that
we can get it back to the right of loner
as quickly and as easily as possible so
that's basically what this de is Bill is
doing and it works in different areas of
437 and
436 and talks about identifying tattoos
and also about making sure that proof of
rabies vaccinations are are done if if
they're not able to know whether they've
had one
before
section c and d are just renaming A and
B section e is the new language and if
you refer to the amendment that I
discussed
0058 it was a small issue that the uh
shelters had with the language that I
proposed and so they asked if we could
change it to the language that is in the
amendment this makes it able for them to
comply with looking at the microchip
industry regist I mean for a
second the final uh section f it was
requested by the shelter industry to put
in this language was currently in rules
and they wanted to make sure that it was
in statute so that it was clear for the
shelters to fall so that was added at
their
request that is pretty much a summary of
the bill I'm going to turn it over I
questions
representative Bix BS you have your hand
raised thank you madam chair uh thank
you member for taking my question um the
um on page um on page one uh the all
dogs cats and ferrets shall be
vaccinated against rabies um the um one
issu one issue I see there and I don't
know if that would be covered under RSA
436 um or if this would as written
create a contradiction but
um dogs and cat dogs and ferrets can't
be uh vaccinated for rabies before three
months of age and cats can't be
vaccinated before two months of age uh
and so it's conceivable that there would
be some small um number of puppies that
uh were baby ferrets
that would uh be available for transfer
but we're not of an age where they could
be um you know medically given uh
medically appropriately given the uh the
vaccine and I was wondering if uh you
that thank you for the question
absolutely thought we had done that but
if if there needs to be a change for
that then certainly that that wants to
consideration thank you reprentative
Pearl is that provision already
indicated in RSA
436 I want to check to be sure but I
thought it was thank you for the
question representative Murray you had a
question I do Madam chair thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
taking my question
uh I so with respect
to um page two down at
the pardon me I'm just trying
to um where the amendment talks about um
RSA 437 colon 8 and
quarantining requirements I was just I
had gone back to take a look at that RSA
and I just wasn't sure if that was
referring
to being held for 48 hours is that I'm
looking specifically at section 4 as
referenced and I just want I wasn't
clear if that was the quarantine that
was being referenced or maybe that's a
veterinarian thank you for the
question don't have 4378 in front of me
but I believe it refers to the 48 hours
if my
you
any we did
have Angela Ferrari who wanted to
SP so Angela Ferrari go right ahead all
right can you hear me now hear you yep
perfect uh thank you again for giving me
a few minutes to speak um I just I want
to provide support for two points on
this bill I don't think I've seen the
latest Amendment so I would like to take
a look at that um but overall I think
this is a good bill dog owners of the
Granite State supports it we don't see
any issue with animal shelter facilities
being a able to operate their business
in a leased property um so we think that
that is a fine addition and then as far
as
um the animal shelter facilities having
to obtain Health certificates for dogs
cats and ferrets who are imported into
New Hampshire for resale um that is
definitely a hole in the current law
that would be wonderful to have written
in um it is my understanding that they
are generally doing that anyway but this
just makes sure that nobody out there
can get away without those Health
certificates um and as you all know from
the health certificate database bill
it's a pretty important thing to be able
to track healthy animals coming into the
state or other diseases that may come up
so we definitely support the addition of
that link language and lastly the piece
about checking microchips um for
registered owners or agents whether
primary or secondary to ensure that all
potential owners are contacted if an
animal is found before it is allowed to
be um sold by the shelter or rescue we
think that that's very important um so
overall just want to provide support on
this bill and take a look at that
Amendment when I get a chance and let
you all know if there is any concerns
there and I would take any
questions thank you do I see any uh
M see n thank you so much for your
testimony
today and is there anybody else who has
a
seeing that um I just report here for
the blue sheet that we have 43
supporting this bill with no oppose um
no opposition so um be there for call
you thank you madam chair I'm gonna take
a about a 10-minute
recess so that the members can stretch
their legs and we're going to come back
and we're going to do few bills for exec
so we'll uh this 10:12 let's reconvene
at 10:25 and we'll do some
you
e
this
[Music]
take
you
right welcome back everybody we back on
sound everybody hear
me yeah okay
here all right we're gonna move on
73 our recognize representative Aaron
for a
motion U I apologize for interrupting
representative uh Pearl but it is
important that if all members are going
to vote that they need to be on screen
during the vote oh thank you Christine I
meant to bring that back up so yes uh
when when you're going when we get to
the roll call porch I'm going to need
everyone to have their camera on that is
not in the room and that I can see when
they
vote okay I'm going to recognize
representative Aaron for a motion on
73o pass on this
bill representative and I recognize you
motion
yes I'm sorry you're right we
do
well I guess I do need a second before
she my apologies is there a second to
motion uh yes this is representative
Duty I would like to second that motion
thank you representative and thank you
for the point of order I representative
may
continue
so so House Bill 73 this bill updates
149s noticing public about Solid Waste
permits include using electronic means
via the department's website and
communicating permitting information
with effective municipalities
electronically as well public hearing
notices regarding Solid Waste perits
must also be posted on the Department's
website along with posting in local
thank you representative is there any
discussion on the representative motion
73 all right seeing
none do we have one representative pix
did you have some discussion yes I just
wanted to point out that this is um a
really um obvious Improvement to uh the
our the dees administrative capabilities
and it seems like it uh it's kind of a
no-brainer so bring us into the 21st
century thank
discussion see none I'll ask the clerk
verville
yes Davis
yes St
yes
yes keny
sor
yes
chair
yes without any objection I will place
this on the consent
none okay excuse me next we will uh move
to House Bill 95 and I will look to
representative hola for a
motion
I9 do we have a
second yes this is represent viny I
second right thank you
representative representative moly you
am
other retain the word War before the
word keeper and it also eliminates the
thank you representative is there any
01908 want see your hands I will ask the
uh clerk to call the role this is on the
[Music]
0190 yes
F
out
yes
yesin
yesz yes chair yes am
motion
all right we have a second for the
motion yes just representative Von
plinsky again I second thank you
representative so the motion on the
floor is to move
hp95 with Amendment Opa with amendment
d019 is there any
discussion uh Mr chair can I just make a
comment yes uh it was my understanding
that when we voted that that everybody
had to be present on uh the screen and I
noticed that some people are not are
they uh in the um are they in the
committee room perhaps yes thank you
representative that's a great question
you have to be president either on
screen or in the committee room that's
correct and uh the members I've verified
that the members that are not on screen
room thank you great question any uh any
hp95
right representative Dix did you have a
question yeah it's I just wanted to make
a comment that um this is a bill that we
had last term and uh representative OK
Conor who was the uh previously the
chair and the ranking member of the
committee did a lot of work on this bill
to make it to get it to the point where
it is and I just like to uh sort of
thank him in absentia uh for having got
us to the point where we where we are
now so uh I just wanted to make that
note on the
bill thank you representative Bixby I
will absolutely second those comments
representative o Conor was did a fine
job as chair when when he was here and
we certainly will miss him on some of
these topics any further conversation
comments
questions
all right seeing on I will ask the clerk
to call the role we are voting on sb95
0190 sorry I guess I moves to the Senate
how about
hp95 with Amendment
202-
yes
yes Davis
yesen
yes
sandor
yes yes
yes
yesy
yes 18 the motion passes 18 to zero
without objection I'd like to put this
on the consent calendar it is an FN bill
in um but because the the U fiscal note
is under $10,000 we're able to put it on
the consent count did you 20 it it was a
question for the chair it was just ask
you all
to thank you representative do we have a
second yeah this is representative Perez
and I would like to Second thank you
representative I will recognize
representative K to speak to a
motion so this is really a
with dat out and also
the enables him to stop produce of U
those
violating and that's
that is really amend
all than you representative and I will
add to it that the uh the Department of
Agriculture asked this amendment
language and the bill itself to come
forward because it does deal with the
sunsetting of the rules so every five
years this rule sunsets and needs to be
questions
ref representative sopus did you have a
hand um yes Mr chairman um could you ask
uh representative comat to check her
microphone because I'm having some
trouble hearing
her okay thank
you repres in the committee room can you
now thank you
comments all right seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call a roll call vote on
amendment number
202-0046
yes
yes yes Davis yes represent stet yes
represent yes represent Kennedy
yes
yes all right so the amendment passes 18
to Zer I will recognize representative
all right so we have a motion of otpa
with on House Bill
226 do I have a second I second that
representative PR thank you
representative all right so we have a
motion in a second do we have any
discussion
right seeing none I will ask the cl to
call the roll on House Bill
226 otpa with amendment number
202-0046
H
yes representative Davis yeses St yes
represent
yes
yes s
yes yes M
yes
representa
yes without any objection I will place
consent
okay next we will EXA House Bill 318 an
act proclaiming the daring jumping
yeah I will recognize representative
Murray for motion yes thank you thank
you Mr chair for recognizing me I'd like
to make a motion of OTP for House Bill
318 an act relative to proclaiming the
daring jumping spider to be the state
spider of New Hampshire we have a
second representative M seconds
representative M you recognized to speak
to your motion thank you um so I in a
year where children have been met with
many challenges their efforts to be
adaptable in bringing our attention to
the attributes of the spider and its
importance to New Hampshire's ecosystem
is commendable so I urge aop
pass thank you
discussion Mr Sher I would like to um
this is a state representative pz I
don't have a question but I would like
to say um I second what Megan said um um
with during this difficult time I really
appreciate all the hard work that our
teachers and student put into uh Bill
three uh 318 I would like to um ask
you thank you representative any further
discussion representative Erin yes thank
you
um also Echo that I think our teachers
and our students have been doing an
amazing job uh the students at the
Hollis school did a wonderful
presentation we learned a lot and uh I
think is absolutely worthy of uh the
legislature to pass this bill so I am
this thank you representative further
discussion
comments
well I would also like to thank the
third grade class uh some of these State
uh bills are you know are sometimes kind
of mundane but these folks did a
wonderful job these kids definitely uh
stepped up showed that they uh they did
their homework they they presented very
well articulated their information that
they presented and uh I I would just
applaud them and I would applaud their
teacher Mrs happy too you you've done a
great job in bringing these kids forward
and in teach teaching them the process
and I wish we were in normal conditions
so they could have the you know the full
effect of coming to the House of
Representatives and and being in the
gallery and being recognized because
it's it's quite an honor we'll certainly
be happy to move this bill forward out
of our
committee all right seeing no other
comments I'm going to ask the clerk to
rooll
yes
sorry
yes Ken
yes yes sand
yes
yes yes Dy yes M
yes yes chair yes pass 18 so I will ask
the committee we can put this on consent
what is the will of the committee do we
want this to be on consent or do we want
to put it on the house floor so to speak
and whatever it presents itself to be
and and have a little discussion on it
what what is the will of the committee
I see representative bix's hand up yeah
um so I think that in uh there actually
needs to be opposition in order to have
a discussion on the house floor and uh
since we voted it uh unanimously I don't
think that the clerk will let us discuss
it on the house
floor thank you representative
viby any further input yes
represent yes well I think that since um
we are unanimous in
this probably do not need to have a
debate on the floor um especially in
this time where uh we have we will have
some work ahead of us and we want get
our our sessions done in an expedient
H thank you representative any further
conversation uh statement yes I believe
that uh consent uh is appropriate and
mention could be made in a pi
briefly if if it goes on the consent
calendar there'll be no Pi it's all done
in one
vote okay thank you uh representative B
question for the chair would it be
possible to put it on the regular
calendar no debate so there's a vot or I
so representative
Duty uh no I didn't quite hear what that
said I think I'm repeating it so it
would be possible to bring them back at
some point when we can meet in rep's
Hall and maybe do a an award or
accomodation or
something uh I don't think we could
bring them back but we could certainly
calendar and it uh you know if the
speaker chose to he could do a mention
as he called the bill okay
representative
sakas thank you Mr chair I just um just
want to put it out there that we know
that there's certain Representatives
that are always against this kind of
Bill and not to overlook the the chance
that it might be taken off consent by
one of those
people thank you representative Bixby
yeah so um another approach if we wanted
to do some recognition would be to uh do
an unanimous consent address and just
you know spend a c two or three minutes
mentioning how well these uh kids did in
our in in their presentation and uh that
would get it out to the Full House
without having to um have a an an
argument or a mock argument or anything
like
that any further comments representative
Aon I would offer that we put it on the
consent calendar and perhaps um draft a
letter from our committee to the school
uh to the teacher and students uh
letting them know um the you know how
the bill was
handled and I think that might be
something too and surely when the
governor signs uh the bill into law
maybe they would be able to have some
sort of reception or something for the
kids
then
I like the sound of all of what we're
giv so I guess it sounds like we should
put the the bill on the consent calendar
and uh representative Bixby if You' like
to do unanimous consent perhaps that's
something uh yourself and in another
Committee Member or or whatever could we
could look at so would everybody be in
agreement with
that
yeah all right then I will place it on
the consent
now
we got time to do one more simple one
before
we
hearing next will EXA house fill 627 7
FNA I will call on representative Bixby
for a motion okay I would like to uh
move retain on uh uh HB 627 and um speak
to my motion do we have a
second yes second all right
representative Aon second representative
Bixby you are are recognized to speak
your motion yes I think that um from the
testimony that we heard and from uh
communication I've gotten from from
other people as well uh there is support
for doing something like this but uh the
mechanisms that uh were in the bill as
presented were not sufficient to do it
right and I think that if we have a
chance to study it uh over the summer
and fall then we can put in uh uh we we
can amend the legislation in order to
bring it back right in the second year
of the bium uh so uh that's uh I hope
that everyone will vote to retain on
this
thanks I would say that while I
appreciate the you know the concept I
agree with representative Bixby that
there were some concerns related to
funding and uh some issues that
representative fby raised that I would
agree and support or retain there any
further
conversation
all right seeing none I will ask the
cour to have call the roll on House Bill
retain
yes
yeses Davis
yes yes Kennedy
Sor
yes
yes yes
yes all right so we will retain this as
a committee and chance to look at it in
the
fall don't believe we have any time
enough time to accept any further bills
prior to our schedule 11: a.m. hearing
so we're going to take about a four
minute break and we'll
a.m.
for
e
good
sh
okay
GNA back into order and I'm going to
turn the
chair chair ince the next
B
good morning again to
everyone I am going to open hearing for
house
36 this bill
[Music]
is good morning again members of the ENA
committee this is representative Howard
Pearl from representing Mar 26 I
represent the towns of Lowden panbury
Northfield bosin and school of Franklin
I'm also the chair of the house
environment
acte I'm here today to introduce House
Bill 366 finding
in this is a bill that I introduced last
year it's kind of an important issue
because we
have excuse me many high-profile cases
that are dealing with the animal fol as
they relate to
foring and foring has certainly been a
part of many of these
cases all too often people with mental
illnesses and related conditions end up
in snowed in the criminal justice system
although improvements have been made and
despite the best efforts of mental
health Advocates our criminal justice
system is not adequate adequately
equipped to handle these
cases at present a mentally ill
defendant's best hope is that his
criminal defend attorney the judge or a
probation officer has enough knowledge
and understanding to detect the need for
a mental health evaluation as part of
the criminal
proceeds animal hoing disorder is a
particularly complex mental health
illness requiring a multidisciplinary
approach giving the individuals
inability to acknowledge their animals
neglect and suffering a high recidivism
rate and increased frequency of
cases teeder of animals and criminal
prosecution alone is an insufficient
resp response in these
situations in the interest of the
animals it would be ideal if the New
Hampshire judicial system could
recognize that an Animal Hoarding
situation may exist to prevent future
animal
cruelty House Bill 366 would insert in
the animal cruelty statute a provision
triggering the question of whether the
defendant being charged might be
suffering from a m mental illness and
desperate need of treatment and not
prosecution all I think this is a very
important issue for our committee to uh
look into and
consider the bill as it's written I
recognize is is good but I think there's
still a couple of areas that we'll want
to take a look at and so as we go
forward and listen to the additional
testimony uh I think it will highlight
some of the areas where the bill is
strong and perhaps some areas where we
still need to look at it as a
committee with that I'm going to uh end
my testimony and I'll be happy to accept
any questions with the caveat that we
have two people and testify behind me
that have a lot more knowledge in this
area than myself so if you have real
technical questions I would encourage
them representative
Bixby yes thank you for taking my
question um I was wondering if uh there
are if you're aware of other areas of
law where statute requires the
evaluation the psychological evaluation
of defendants and if you use that as a
model for uh the language that you have
here I am not and this was some language
that I worked with OSS and just
explained to him what I was trying to do
and this is the way that they put it
together and recommended that we proceed
again I think there's some areas within
the the criminal justice code that we
perhaps need to look a little further at
this because I there's a stipulation
where we may be putting officers in the
position to make a mental health
judgment that they may not be qualified
to make so again I recognize there areas
that we still need to work on this thank
question thank you uh representative
Duty H yes thank you for taking my
question when I read the bill I seem to
it seems to be equating hoarding with a
mental illness um first of all is that
what you wanted and secondly are there
couldn't there be instances where
hoarding is due to another issue and not
necessarily a mental
illness there certainly could be I mean
reporting disorder in in itself again
there's there's some folks that are
going to speak behind me that speak very
knowledgeably to that more than I will
but there definitely is a correlation
between hoarding disorder in other areas
of their life and hoarding animals in
many cases maybe not in every case in I
mean the biggest thing that we're
concerned with here is that animals are
cared for properly I certainly don't
want the legislature to be deciding how
many animals any one person can have
that is not my intent as long as the
animals are cared for and done so
appropriately then you know it's not the
state's concern as to how many animals
anyone has but when the the uh situation
becomes that the animals are not being
cared for properly and and there's
identified that there's a problem
certainly hoarding disorder does come
into play in some of these cases and and
it would it would better serve the
defendant in some cases if the language
is correct that they would be able to
move through the process quicker and it
certainly would serve the animals and
concern thank
you thank
you representative muray you think your
hand out I did thank you madam chair for
taking my question and thank you to the
sponsor for taking my question uh on a
similar vein I guess I was just curious
I know that we are seeing in criminal
justice avenues that there are drug
Courts are there or or are you aware of
any scenario where there are like a
mental health advocacy court or anything
of that nature um to be able to in in I
guess dovetail onto representative
Duty's Point um we without the careful
consideration of folks who are trained
to make that assertation wouldn't want
to
um make a judgment prior to that
being done
carefully thank you for the question and
certainly that's a great consideration
and and again there there's an area here
where we're asking law enforcement I
feel to make a a decision that I'm not
positive there ready to make yet as as
far as the first part of your question I
think um one of the next people that are
coming will be able to speak to what's
currently available in law a lot better
than I will so I I'll defer that portion
of the question to one of the the other
speakers that's coming thank you for the
question
any other members of the
no I would like to call Stacy ogre to
testify and please state your name your
state
morning sorry it looks like my zoom just
had me log out and log back in I'm just
taking the
um there I can join you by video as well
good morning thanks for the opportunity
to speak with all of you and I'm
grateful that uh chairman Pearl has
refiled this bill for your consideration
my name is Stacy obber I am the
government relations contact for the
American Kennel Club and this bill was
filed last year um released by the
committee and approved by the house last
March I just want to acknowledge that uh
the American Kennel Club Works to ensure
that the rights of responsible owners
and breeders are protected but also that
anyone regardless of the number of dogs
they own
who treats a dog negligently or cruy is
held responsible for those
actions this bill is about those
occasions where an individual's neglect
or cruel treatment of animals is not the
result of Criminal Intent or activity
but instead is a symptom of uh a mental
illness known as Animal Hoarding
disorder and when these cases come to
light people may draw simplified but
inaccurate conclusions that anyone who
owns a certain number of dogs for
instance cannot adequately care for them
and this can result in proposals that
either limit or restrict dog ownership
but in the end does nothing to address
the underlying mental illness that cause
the serious health and safety problems
for uh both people and pets in the WR
written testimony that I submitted to
the committee I provide specific New
Hampshire cases uh where
it's I guess suspected that in fact
these were Animal Hoarding disorder
situations and individuals who suffer
from the disorder often deny their
failure to provide adequate Animal Care
and they also deny the deplorable
conditions under which they're living
and it's unfortunate but uh few
recognize that Animal Hoarding disorder
is
uh a mental health illness and that it
is a significant Community concern um
because not only are the animals harmed
but excuse me humans are too including
everyone that's living under these
unsanitary conditions and also anyone in
the surrounding Community who might be
impacted as well um in addition to my
written testimony I just wanted to
acknowledge with you all that a Dr Gary
patronek was a veterinarian at tus
veterinary school which is the only vet
School here in New England and he was on
the faculty and spent a lot of time
studying this particular subject and had
done multiple studies and I just wanted
to share a couple of Statistics with you
all um he concluded that Animal Hoarding
disorder causes more animal suffering
than all acts of intentional cruelty
combined and one of his studies of
Cruelty charges in Animal Hoarding cases
across the United States He determined
that uh dogs and cats were the most
popular animals that were hoarded and
that only
26% of the animal cruelty cases in which
charges were filed and information was
available indicated
that courts ordered a defendant to
undergo a pre-trial psychological
assessment or any mental health
evaluation and this is despite Court's
having both the discretion and the
budget to require a psychological
evaluation of defendant um the reason is
some courts may not understand that a
diagnosable mental health issue is the
real cause of the animal cruelty in the
first place and also the data in the
literature show that without treating
the
psychological um disorder itself 100% of
animal hoarders will repeat their
behavior so uh what some states have
begun to do is to pass laws that
specifically require courts to order a
psychological evaluation and treatment
if necessary when charges of animal
cruelty are filed and so to answer
rep's uh question about you know whether
or not there's anything in New Hampshire
Statute in the written testimony that I
submitted to you all I do have reference
to a section of the animal cruelty
Statute in New Hampshire uh that refers
to beastiality and there is language
there that um highlights a court
ordering psychological evaluation and
treatment in an animal cruelty of case
of that nature and I've also shared with
you the exact language from other New
England states that have in fact
included language more as a raising
awareness um in the animal cruelty
statute that in fact uh a defendant
that's before the court may be suffering
from Animal Hoarding disorder um my
colleague Eileen casy who is an expert
clinician in this area and has the
mental health background um I believe is
registered to testify this morning and
can answer any detailed questions you
might have um about the disorder uh but
the bill in and of itself it's our hope
would more or less raise the flag for
the criminal justice system that a
defendant who's brought before the court
May in fact be in need of a
psychological evaluation and perhaps
treatment so we can avoid this repeat
repeat pattern of collecting animals um
by someone who's left untreated in the
community so that's that's basically why
the bill was
filed thank
you thank you for that uh do we have any
over I don't see any questions so thank
you very much for your
would excuse me um I would like to Now
call eileene
Daisy please state your name town and
state yes hello everyone my name is
Eileen Daisy and I am a licensed
independent clinical social worker in
the state of Massachusetts
joining you all from
Melrose um I wanted to share some
remarks in support of this particular
bill on Animal
Hoarding so I prepared some some written
testimony here Animal Hoarding is a
complex often misunderstood and
underrecognized public health problem
affecting both animal and human welfare
typical responses to Animal Hoarding
cases include involuntary seizure of the
animals and prosecution of the
individual who hoarded the animals this
approach can yield up to 100% of reivisa
hoarding cases due to professionals only
focusing on the symptom of the issue
which is the accumulated animals this
approach fails to recognize that the
collection of animals is congruent with
a diagnosable mental health disorder
without meical and carefully
orchestrated psychotherapeutic approach
the individual will continue their
Animal Hoarding Behavior at a much more
rapid rate so meaning accumulating more
animals including
Strays therefore prohibiting the person
from adopting or buying new pets is also
an ineffective approach Animal Hoarding
is classified as an additional specifier
under the clinical mental health
diagnosis of hoarding disorder in the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders also known as the
dsm5 of which I'd like to share that
diagnostic criteria with you all and it
is as follows a failure to provide
minimal standards of Sanitation space
nutrition and veterinary care for the
animals followed by that there's a
presence of the inability to recognize
the adverse effects on the welfare of
the animals the residents residing in
the home and the home environment as a
whole and lastly this is coupled with
the presence of obsessive attempts to
accumulate or maintain a collection of
animals despite the two deteriorating
conditions of the animals and the
environment lastly the person presents
with denial or even minimization of
evident problems regarding the living
conditions for the person and animals
three dis distinct types of
characteristics are also identified when
we're considering Animal Hoarding cases
the typology is as follows number one
there's um one that we think of we
classify as an overwhelmed
caregiver secondly um someone might be
considered a rescuer so feeling this
compulsive need to continue to
accumulate animals and then lastly there
might be one which is a little bit more
rare which is considered an exploit are
type this is important um to recognize
typology because it can inform the type
of intervention a mental health provider
can take as well as anyone else who
might be a part of that team likee
approach so harm reduction is a
suggested pragmatic technique when
addressing Animal Hoarding cases so
meaning that working with the person to
minimize risks through concrete and
objective goals so some harm reduction
strategies include developing rapport
with the individual question offering
psycho education on ways to
appropriately care for the animals which
can include spay and neutering the
animals outlined check-ins or visits by
such stakeholders that are involved in
the case and potentially referrals to
ongoing longer term
treatment we must also consider that the
animals when they are removed and
considering their behavior and their
outcomes as well so when considering
what that might look like medical and
behavioral issues of the animals can
lead to difficulties in adoption and
even longer term placements overcrowding
in local shelters can also lead to
unnecessary euthanasia referred to as
the caring killing Paradox within the
field therefore it's critical to explore
the ways of minimizing and resolving
risk with the resident first before
exploring some of those further options
lastly the psychiatric provider assigned
to the case as mandated by the court
should determine the appropriate length
of time for the recommended amount of
sessions as outlined within the
therapeutic treatment plan the
therapeutic approach should be directive
with co-created goals by both the
therapist and the client um and this can
include ways that reunification may be
possible as well if animals are placed
within temporary
custody um just to to provide some some
preface here or some background I am a
clinical social worker in the state of
Massachusetts and I specialize in the
treatment of hoarding disorder and I
have worked with a number of cases that
do also entail both Animal Hoarding as
well as possession hoarding so thank you
for your
time thank you so much for that
testimony do we have any questions from
members of the
yes you please email me your testimony
yes
absolutely representative
Bixby yes um I was wondering if there is
a a a track track record for the
therapeutic approach you've laid out and
and what that track record is okay
that's a great question um so the
therapeutic approach that I've laid out
um in case
of entailing hoarding disorder if an
individual is actually involved in
ongoing therapy um and is committed to
the required number of sessions so
typical number of sessions might be
anywhere from 24 to 26 sessions in total
um generally on a weekly basis that's
that's what's recommended we can see
about
46% Effectiveness
literature thank you um representative
question uh yes thank you for taking my
question uh what is uh can you go
through the process of how you get a
referral so at the time of somebody
makes a complaint about an animal and at
that point can you walk us through that
process about how it gets to
you I think that's a great question
thank you um so I've you know I have to
be quite Frank is that a lot of my work
here in New England and in Massachusetts
is Raising awareness that these types of
cases should entail collaboration with
mental health support so unfortunately a
lot of Animal Hoarding cases may only
involve um Animal Welfare for instance
um so through ongoing Outreach and
collaboration with the MSPCA as well as
the Animal Rescue League for instance as
well as Animal Control Officers here
within our state um I then am informed
of a case through any of those Avenues
as opposed to just self-referral
only so one of those types of
professionals will contact me directly
and inform me that they've come across a
case and that they would like my
involvement with that particular case
and then from there I will take steps to
meet with those parties and then plan
what should that next step look like I
will share that at this point I'm also
working um and I I sit on the Statewide
steering committee for hoarding here in
Massachusetts so at this point what that
means is that this is sort of um a
collaboration of all of the hoarding
task forces within our Commonwealth and
we're trying to inform each of those
task force is that should they come
across an Animal Hoarding case what
should they do what should that look
like so again trying to increase
awareness and increase Outreach and
collaboration with animal control um
throughout the state overall and knowing
and letting them know that there is uh
mental health support that's
available Madam chair may I have a
followup
certainly uh thank
you uh uh where does the court um come
into this process or does it not at at
at this
point okay um so at this point the cases
that I've worked on have been U managed
within the community prior to getting to
to the
court for instance however if if charges
are filed um we would then be mindful of
um then you know should it proceed
before the court what what can we do um
I have to say that I do not have
experience once it's gotten to that
level thank you you're
welcome thank you very much uh
representative ston you have your
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I missed the
boarding typologies you mentioned three
of them could you go over those briefly
again please yes absolutely so the three
typologies um we have um the first
typology which is considered an
overwhelmed
caregiver so that means that perhaps
I'll give an example that as someone has
aged for instance um their circumstances
whether it's physical cognitive or even
Financial have changed the way in which
they can continue to care for the animal
so perhaps the number of animals they
had at one point was within re reason
and over time it it it then became out
of their control um whenever Mental
Health Providers or other professionals
are involved in such cases um things
tend to be a little bit more seamless
and we're able to get much more
cooperation from the resident the second
typology is considered um what we would
deem a rescuer so someone who we have we
can see a little bit more of that
compulsive like act that is really
prevalent um within this particular
Disorder so an impulsive need or urge to
continue to accumulate animals even if
there are really adverse effects within
the environment so deteriorating
conditions of the environment
deteriorating conditions of the animals
within the space or even potentially
deceased animals the last typology um
and again I mentioned that this is a
little bit more rare when thinking about
this particular disorder is something
called or classified as an exploiter
type I have not had experience with this
particular type I've communicated with
other professionals even across the
country and they indicate that their
encounters with this type is also rather
rare so that means we can break that
that typology down a little bit further
is that someone will continue to
accumulate animals um based off of other
um monetary Gaines or other needs so
there's a lack of attachment to the
animal in and of itself um so you might
see this when you're thinking about say
um overbreeding of animals for instance
or or puppy mill like
situations thank you very much you're
welcome
okay um representative Murray you had a
question I did uh thank you madam chair
for taking my question um and thank you
um Miss Daisy for taking my question as
you are aware there are many other um
mental health conditions Beyond uh the
disorder class of obsessive disorders um
in hoarding with regard to the dsm5 and
what is your assessment of the ability
for fure first responding whether it's
as you said in the community whether
it's a law enforcement officer or an
animal rights officer coming out to take
a look to be able to know what to do
once they might suspect that there is a
mental health issue
there okay um great question um and
you're Keen to to pick up on that as
well so um to provide background
boarding disorder does fall under the
obsessive compulsive disorder or OCD and
related disorder
Spectrum um so there's a lot of
similarity a lot of overlap and even
some
differences um and of those with hording
disorder about 92% of those will also
present with another existing
comorbidity meaning another mental
health diagnosis whether it's diagnosed
or
undiagnosed when providers are first
encountering a case um so a lot of my
professional experience has in training
law enforcement across Massachusetts as
part of their preliminary mental health
engagement and training with individuals
within the community um is being able to
take an opportunity to assess the
situation and also find an opportunity
to develop any type of rapport with the
resident um and so what I mean by assess
the situation is first taking a look at
what risks might be um evident within
the space
as well as risk for the individual and
risk for the animals as well and them
reacting based off of those imminent
risks if there are imminent risks that
are there um so whether that means okay
there are concerns but we can step away
from the situation and then plan for
followup but over the course of that
time before followup occurs does that
also mean filing a report or um a file
to say Adult Protective Services or
child protective services so if we're
thinking about dependent individuals
within the home or even if the resident
is elderly themselves and there are
space I hope that answers your question
no it does thank you for taking you're
welcome you for that and uh
representative Highland you had a
question thank you madam chair for
taking my
question um
my so my question has to do with I guess
it's not necessarily a question but more
of would you
recommend what would okay what would you
recommend as a follow-up
procedure this person or these cases go
through kind of what we've been talking
about maybe they do go go through a
court system and as per how it reads
there is an evaluation you know an
evaluation might be
recommended and there's a mental health
professional that goes through what that
treatment process would look like as
you've already we've already been
through some of that as far as the court
system or the municipality
or I guess what would you recommend is a
follow-up procedure because I feel like
maybe that might need in in my opinion
might need some discussion thank
you okay all right thank you
representative Highland um you know my
recommendation my strong recommendation
is engagement with therapeutic support
so whether that's through the court
system or within the community okay um
so if it's within the court system then
a referral to um an actual psychological
evaluation to determine first and
foremost is this actually Animal
Hoarding right is that what the the
person is presenting with um so
identifying what that presenting problem
is then informs the course of treatment
um and then if it is Animal Hoarding
right is is actually then thinking about
a referral to ongoing treatment and
going through that entire process the
same process would occur within the
community as well um but within the
community there then needs to be a
little bit more of a discussion of what
that means for the person to actually
engage so if it's just law enforcement
for instance having that conversation
with a resident hey I think I need you
to connect with a counselor the person
might State no I'm not interested but if
law enforcement came out to the
residents um in collaboration with a
mental health supporter such as such as
myself a mental health provider can then
have that conversation around what this
would actually mean what would that look
like to actually get connected with
therapy and to think about the ways in
which perhaps
maintaining care for the animals has
been problematic in their own lives how
can we enhance that together so then
becomes a little bit more of a dactic
and collaborative conversation and
therefore that that yields a higher
chance that the person's actually going
to want to participate in
therapy thank you you're
welcome okay uh actually I have a
question interested to know if you are
aware of a network of therapists in New
Hampshire that specifically deal with
animal boarding
issues okay great question thank you I
am not aware of any particular
Specialist or therapist that has great
specialty in treating hoarding disorder
or Animal Hoarding Behavior within New
Hampshire however what I will add to
that is that considering hoing disorder
is within the
dsm5 that means that a mental health
provider should be able to take on the
case um considering that we've all gone
through this process as clinicians that
we are well-versed within the DSM and if
a case is referred to a therapist it's
our ethical obligation that if we feel
we really can't take it on that we
should make those proactive steps of
connecting them with the appropriate
provider who's more equipped in taking
on that particular
case thank you because um the only
reason why I would ask that is say an
animal control officer sees you know
comes upon
situation where somebody
has you know a hoarding well looks like
a hoarding situation so I wonder is
there like a list of special therapists
that then they would contact once the
animals are confiscated or you know how
I'm trying to figure how the whole
process would play
out I think that that would require
further conversation exploration and the
development probably of some sort of a
compiled list or resource directory so
something of that nature exists here in
Mass
Massachusetts um and it would be
beneficial if that were a mirrored also
within New
Hampshire thank you so much um I see
representative Bixby your hand is still
up did you still have a
question yes I I actually have a
separate question um so I was wondering
uh if there is an issue well how is the
monetary end of uh access to mental
health dealt with because um I don't
know that there's I that that there is
any sort of mechanism readily available
for paying for uh these sorts of
surfaces particularly when the um the
the person involved might not be aware
it
okay
um that's a complicated question um
considering that again hoarding disorder
is within the dsm5 that means that um a
a mental health provider can actually
bill for the services under their health
insurance plan um Medicare Medicaid even
commercial private insurance plans as
well um if an individual is not quite um
interested in engaging in Services I
think that that yields a different
convers ation right so that means that
the case will likely not then get opened
for ongoing
treatment um a lot of Outreach
mechanisms do exist throughout our
country so such as whether those are
senior centers or Council on Aging often
will have an Outreach social worker
that's embedded within that type of of
an agency who may get involved in
hoarding cases um and then their
services or their time is then covered
under their agency so I use that as an
example because of the agency that I
worked for my time was covered under my
agency and therefore I was able to
engage and participate with law
enforcement with no cost to the
individual some agencies such as and
I'll use MSPCA or Animal Rescue League
again as an example had access to Grant
funds as another alternative right um so
that if an individual was uninsured for
instance that perhaps they could
contract my services so that I could
then get engaged and um and help the
individual whether it was short-term or
even some sort of a longer term process
so I just wanted to provide you with
some options to consider because there
could be some possibilities for the
explore okay thank you for that and um I
see still representative dsy have your
hand
up
oops you're muted H okay no I hit the
wrong button sorry thank you for thank
you for taking my question I want to
make a comment first and then I want to
ask you a question uh the first comment
is in my first life I was a psychiatric
social worker and I worked at the
greater Manchester Mental Health Center
so throughout the state of New Hampshire
we do have mental health centers um you
know and I agree with you a a uh social
worker uh could be would be trained or
their background would easily uh allow
them uh to work in this field because
they normally would work with people um
who have issues with denial or obsessive
compulsive disorders so it's just
basically a subset of that so I think
from what we have in place in our Mental
Health Community we would be able to um
be able to assess and and treat these
people so that's number one number two
is how many cases do you uh actively
have opened and how many cases of
hoarding do you typically see in a
year
okay thank you my entire specialty as a
clinician
is working with cases that entail
hoarding Disorder so each of my cases
that I have open currently are actually
cases where the individual is presenting
with hoarding
Behavior I have at this time trying to
think about my case load is about maybe
individuals okay I may see um perhaps up
to 100 within any given
year
I didn't provide prevalence I think that
that's important as well so if we think
about hoarding disorder within the
country in it of itself um Research
indicates that there is a prevalence of
anywhere from two to up to six% of the
US population that makes hoarding
disorder actually the most common mental
country
okay thank you for that um I see head up
from representative
Kennedy thank you madam
chair about wording inside document line
12 where it says immediate danger to be
animals or life and there's not
sufficient time to obtain order could
you also possibly add somewhere
that the caregivers help could be
dangerous since we are talking about a
mental disorder um and
where fac not
enough
it's but it possibly be added in there I
wor I think that that's a discussion
um all
right and representative Highland you
had your hand
up thank you um most of my questions
have been answered since you all have
asked awesome questions but I do have a
question about um you said that
Massachusetts has a system for
contacting therapists specifically for
hoarding or um you know maybe within the
mental health uh system there do you I
would like to know more about that but
also I have a question about
municipality involvement that we talked
about with followup um could there be in
would you recommend shelter involvement
as far as providing information like an
information resource or or some sort of
M Municipal resources for putting
information out to the public somehow I
mean I just see the breakdown of finding
help I guess is is where my question is
coming from thank you and thank you
question okay thank you representative
Highland um so the the resource
directory that currently exists in the
state of
Massachusetts um again was developed and
continues to be maintained by the
Statewide steering committee on hoarding
um and so there is an actual site that
any one can access and locate resources
whether that means it's just mental
health support for hoarding or even if
an individual is looking for biohazard
cleanup or hoarding remediation and so
the whole gamut is sort of there um but
if we take it a step further um there
are of course other National sites that
individuals can access when they're
looking for a therapist in particular um
who specializes in the treat of hoarding
Disorder so for some examples might be
looking at Psychology today for instance
right and then there are filters right
where you say this is the city that the
individual lives in this is the
presenting problem which would be hoing
and then this is the insurance that the
person has and the no filter to show a
listing of the therapists within that
area that can respond um then the iocdf
website is also a national website that
individuals can access so again that
goes back to my point of hoarding
disorder following falling under the OCD
and related disorder spectrum and so
that also has an up-to-date list as well
um in terms of your question um around
municipality involvement or other
resources even potentially shelters
within the area I think that again there
probably should be some detailed
conversation
around and even some Outreach if at all
necessary so talking within um say any
of the animal welfare or rescue um
organizations across the state who can
they reach out to should they come
across a particular instance and then
that the same goes for shelters as well
um I think that that then we just there
should be conversation around what does
that compiled list really consist of who
are the therapists that people can reach
out to and where and what should that
look
like so I know that that's a little
vague but thank you I just may I ask a
follow-up question sure mam thank you um
you said that Mass sorry you said that
the US had about a two to six% hoarding
um so what do you do you know the I
guess you don't know the New Hampshire
number do you do you know the
Massachusetts number I'm trying to get a
feel for what our state might have but
obviously we need I need to do my
research on that but if you have the
mass number that would be great thank
you you're W you're welcome
representative Highland um I do not have
the actual Massachusetts number and
therefore I do not have the actual New
Hampshire number um and because those
numbers you know they would need to be
tested they would need to be published
within literature um we can't just break
down that percentage into Geographic
locations or that would just be false
information that would be a
fallacy thank you for your time you're
welcome okay I see um uh representative
Murray your hand is still
up thank you uh thank you madam chair
and thank you m speak closer to the uh
microphone yes and thank you for is that
better yeah okay thank you for taking my
question so you had mentioned that there
is a possibility that in addition to the
Animal Hoarding disorder that might be
identified that there are other
situations that might be comorbidities
that go along with uh something that is
being presented um with a patient or an
individual and so what happens if you
had mentioned um generally 24 to
26 treatments or insurance for insurance
purposes what what if it exceeds that
what if the care needs to go beyond that
um what do the coverages look like for a
patient or an individual that you're
typically seeing with respect to
Insurance okay so in in that situation
um representative Murray if um these
sessions exce or need to exceed the
recommended um treatment plan for
instance further Insurance authorization
would need to be um pursued and a
that followup if I
may sure go right ahead um and and
generally how long does it take to at
least in your circumstance to get a
patient um to treatment or care for
provider care how long is it to find an
nature okay um great question again
thank you representative Murray um in in
my circumstances or in my experience um
it I haven't seen a lot of lag time so
if I'm able to be there physically
myself and have that conversation with
the person um or even if I know that the
case might need to be referred out just
because for Geographic reasons it just
makes more sense to connect them with a
therapist that's closer to where they
reside um in my experience it's been
anywhere from up to a month um in total
maximum of getting them connected Ed
with a therapist and getting them
therapy okay thank you and uh
representative
Bixby yes thank you madam Sher for
taking my question and thank you uh Miss
Daisy for uh uh taking it um so one of
the things that we see in these hoarding
cases is um uh when when when it gets
Beyond a certain point is um real sort
of public horror and outrage at the
conditions that the animals are are
facing and uh often a rather than a
um uh a will on the part of the public
to to look for a cure but a desire to
look for punishment and I was wondering
how that plays into the um the Practical
aspects of trying to get uh treatment
people yes representative Bixby
unfortunately I think that we've all
heard of those those sort of horror
stories if you will and of course not
every case entails um that type of
severity um you know I of course want to
recommend um that within the community
providers are as proactive as possible
um to ensure that a case doesn't reach
that level of magnitude if if if that is
possible in any way shape or form um I
can understand that the public would
then want to pursue more punitive
measures want to look for punishment
within those circumstances because we
are thinking about animals and we're
thinking about their welfare right um
but we also need to be mindful of course
that this is a mental health concern as
well and thinking just within punitive
reivisa again they're going to
accumulate more animals we're going to
see the same cycle occur over and over
and over again so thinking about full
treatment and not just focusing on
prohibition or just the symptoms of the
problem which might be for seizures of
all of the animals for instance but
thinking about getting the person help
and whatever help is actually defined
for that case think we're going to see a
different outcome at least in my
experience I've seen different outcomes
as well as the experiences of some of my
colleagues
Nationwide okay um thank you very much
uh Miss Daisy and I just wanted to in
show that uh we are coming up in a heart
break at 12
o' um and I do know that uh Miss obber
still has her hand up so I would like to
give her an opportunity just for a brief
moment to say what she would like to say
and then uh if we have any further
discussion we're going to have to take
that to another time so go ahead and it
is over thank thank you I appreciate all
of you taking the time to hear the
details about this uh problem and some
proposed solutions to address it I I did
want to share that I had a
conversation uh probably two months ago
with a judge down in Baltimore Baltimore
Maryland who sits on a mental health
court and she had a serious Animal
Hoarding uh case that came before her
and it prompted her uh she is in the
middle of drafting a manual for judges
that would be a reference around best
practices for any judge that might
encounter an Animal Hoarding disorder
case uh because in her um experience
it's this is not the kind of case that
you going to routinely see it may be in
the um over your career as a judge you
may only end up having you know one case
come before you so she's publishing this
manual uh soon and I just wanted to
acknowledge in New Hampshire I do
understand that you have uh mental
health drug Courts for those suffering
from substance use disorder and I know
that um last year there had been a
commission in New Hampshire to look at
expanding mental health courts in your
state which are really designed to be
problemsolving courts that would allow
the kind of oversight and followup that
I think everyone is acknow in would be a
crucial element to any uh approach in
treating somebody with this disorder but
perhaps it is developmental in first uh
enacting some language like House Bill
366 to again raise awareness and help
educate the judges in New Hampshire um
and the the criminal justice system that
in fact this may be um a result of of
Animal Hoarding disorder you know that
has created these charges coming forward
and to best respond thank you well thank
you thank you so very much for those
additional comments and uh and
information and uh I am going to uh call
this hearing closed um since we are on
this uh heart break so um thank you
everyone all right I want to thank
everyone who testified on the bill so
we're going to be in recess until 12 and
I'll just remind uh excuse me one and I
just want to remind everyone on the
committee that if you uh get your
committee recommendations in to me in
the next 24 hours or so if you were uh
the one that uh made the motion to move
a bill forward if you need assistance
with that certainly uh feel free to
reach up to me all right we're going to
take a break and we will see you back at
statea Tucker is the prime sponsor to
bill
mute am I unmuted now all right we got
you now thank you
representative I it's taking me a while
to figure out the new Arrangements my
name is uh Edith Tucker I'm a
representative who represents four towns
in Coos County uh the largest is the
town of Whitefield that has about 2500
people I also represent
Jefferson carol which includes Bretton
Woods and Twin Mountain and my own
little town of 300 of
Randolph so Whitefield is my largest
town that I represent and I paid close
attention last year when their town
meeting in
20120 uh on a petitioned ward article
number
40 voted uh handily to be opposed to
having a landfill in their town near
Forest Lake State
Park and when I was asked later to by
people enthusiastic about uh prohibiting
a landfill within two miles of state
parks in New Hampshire to be the prime
sponsor I was more than happy to agree
to do that
and I think what's important to
recognize about my district and much of
Coos County is that we are increasingly
a tourist based economy I in my district
have two grand hotels the Omni Mount
Washington in Breton woods and the
mountain view grand in
Whitefield then in addition to those
those great big hotels that ordinarily
when we don't have a pandemic truly hire
hundreds of people through the year we
have Mom and Pop restaurants cabins
motels and although people are trying
to uh develop and continue with
manufacturing it's a hard push in Coos
where we're so far away from uh
metropolitan areas
so
tourism has become more and more
important so the idea of having a state
park become the site right next to it of
a landfill is just
startling this particular Park is one of
the 35 uh 10 uh parks that were the
first parks that were bought by New
Hampshire in 193 35 and it's a Charming
Park
um people who know about landfills and
have visited them as I have uh know that
even those that are well-run there is
odor there's Trucking there's
noise and there's cleared land to open
up the
landfills and it's not something you
want in a tourist area and not something
you want next to a state
park uh people in Whitefield believe
that they will have gears of
degradation and really no particular
return to the town itself and that is
why the selectman sent a letter to the
governor executive counsel senators and
representatives asking that such a bill
as this uh and be done be passed so that
this would not happen in their town so I
am here really at the behest of the
Selectmen and the town meeting of
Whitefield it's not just a few people
who live in a particular spot in
Whitefield it is the town of Whitefield
itself and their Selectmen that want
this uh landfill not to happen there
this morning as I understand it I was at
ways and means but um our uh Taylor
Caswell was on the exchange and
apparently he came out against having
this
landfill uh in Whitefield in that part
of Coos County because he sees
that the pandemic has made us even more
aware that people want to be outdoors
they want beautiful places to go they
want to have a places where people can
live and work and play and have a
balanced life and as you probably know
they had a ability to hire a new person
to be sort of in charge of promoting
outdoors in New Hampshire in a much more
comprehensive and organized way and
they've just gotten permission to go
ahead and hire such a person so as you
may know Taylor Caswell himself uh comes
from Littleton he knows the area he
knows what it can support and can be
developed here in a sustainable economy
the other person who is also very
interested in this park because he
believes that in the almost 400 Acres
there is place for a state campground to
be built on the existing state park and
that's Phil Bryce another person who
spent a good bit of his life in the
North Country he was a Forester when I
first met him uh at Crown Vantage the uh
Pulp and Paper company that of course is
no longer uh part of the Berlin scene he
then went to work forest and lands
then he left for Private Industry came
back and now is director of parks and he
knows this park and he knows what can
happen for the good in the North Country
so I think it's interesting that these
two people who are in the state's
employee and interested in the economy
are both people who see that a landfill
would not be a good thing
to have at this state park and I think
although I have not personally been to
every state park by any means in New
Hampshire I think that the idea of a
two- mile buffer around our state parks
in which landfills could not be cited is
a perfectly
reasonable
uh thought it's not as much as some
people would like it to be but I think
it would protect
uh the investment and
the Really the appeal of our Park system
to have such a
provision
so I
really I very much would like to see
this bill
passed uh I think it's a better Bill
actually than passed the house last year
and then died through
the uh pandemic
it is a simpler bill it doesn't bring up
any federal land issues which uh the
previous Bill did so I think the
Simplicity of this one is to the good
and I very much would ask that you give
real consideration to passing this I
think it's an excellent Bill I'm very
proud to be the prime sponsor and I'm
ready to answer any questions that you
might have
thank you representative are there any
questions for representative Tucker
representative B thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative Tucker for
taking my question um you talked a
little bit about how state parks in New
Hampshire tend to bring in a lot of
Tourism uh my state park of choice is
White Lake in Tam and every time I go
there I notice that a lot of uh I'm
sorry that more than half the cars in
the parking lot have Massachusetts
license plates people Massachusetts are
going to drive two or even three hours
especially what I didn't hear the
question I heard that that you have a
park in Tamworth and you see a lot of
Massachusetts plates I'm having a little
trouble actually hearing the question
representative would you be able to
repeat that yeah can you hear me any
better now representative Tucker I I
think so okay maybe pull the mic a
little
B if I just hear the actual question
that you're asking yeah I've noticed
that a lot of um residents of
Massachusetts are willing to drive two
or three hours up to our parks in the
North country and I'm wondering why you
think that is that they're willing to
drive so far those
Parks well I think one of the reasons is
that the parks the state parks are not
really overdeveloped state parks um not
that there aren't very nice campgrounds
nice Trails but they're pretty simple
and I think that's what people are
looking for now it's it's a um desire to
go back in time um I've been I was not a
yearr round resident for many many years
in Randolph my family came here in the
Summers uh my
grandfather uh mapped the White
Mountains for the Appalachian Mountain
Club LS F cutter and the fam's been
coming from around the world to New
Hampshire in the Summers and still does
I think that New Hampshire has kept a
Simplicity about its parks that are very
very
appealing and farest lake is one of
those Parks it's
um very simple park I think the idea of
a Campground there is excellent and I'm
sure that if he has his way uh director
happens yeah thank you for taking my
followup um I imagine that these people
tend to spend the weekend or maybe even
a whole week when they visit these Parks
because they're driving so far and to
stay in local hotels in the North
country and they spend probably
significant amounts of money going out
to eat and so on I know a l of people
that are going to testify today are
concerned about uh small new campure
businesses could you articulate at all
the economic toll that small businesses
in an area like Dalton or Whitefield
would take if tourists stopped coming to
a particular area because it developed
maybe a bad reputation due to let's say
a pervasive
follower well I think that um
I I think that the restaurants like
Grandma's Kitchen in in Whitefield which
is having a tough time during the
pandemic but it's a delightful
restaurant where everything is home you
know cooked from scratch in the kitchen
and the prices are right it's a
cross-section of people locals and
tourists who stop and uh those little
businesses where people have an
entrepreneurial chance uh
um really add to the feeling that you're
moving back in time on the other hand
the other end of the spectrum where the
mountain view grand has conventions and
weddings the omy Mount Washington you
know they will have four and five
weddings going in different sections of
the hotel at once uh I've been a
reporter up here and I've covered a lot
of events and you know the the primary
season is
fun uh in the summer before the
primaries and so people like the fact
that
there's high high uh cost great luxury
really a beautiful setting and for
things like weddings and
reunions
there things like the Mount Washington
uh Cog Railway or the auto Road there's
a lot to do that is some of them are
walking in the woods that cost nothing
or a parking fee if it's a national
forest uh and others are um you know
there's there simple and this costly and
I think people like
that uh jux
Theos and it um it interests me that I'm
sorry that I was at Ways and Means and
didn't get to hear uh
uh commissioner Caswell talk about his
thoughts for uh developing our economy
more into the outdoors but I do think
that's something that one of the few
things that we can say that has happened
that because of the pandemic that was
good and that is that people became more
aware that they need to be outdoors they
need nature
and that
supports really this bill and
uh but I it's a tremendous amount
of tourism in Coos sad to see the Mills
go those were a way of life and terrific
jobs but those particular kind of jobs
are not going to come
back all right thank you
recogniz today I do have a question
though you know
mention that there are signicant number
of hotels and bring bring the microphone
right close to your mouth please can you
hear me now yeah just speak right into
it put put it yeah okay I'll try oh yeah
that's good so you mentioned that uh you
know we have a significant number of
hotels uh some of them rather large and
we also have you know so many um
tourists that come up to the North
Country on a regular basis uh they stay
the weekend and
whatnot do you have an idea how much
trash is uh produced by the tourists or
by the hotels in the North
Country they do have there is trash and
fortunately uh two of the towns that I
represent are members of the Andre kogen
Valley uh Regional Refuge disposal
District I always remember forget so
Berlin dummer Errol gorum Jefferson
milin North umberland Randolph and
Stark uh are in a Consortium of towns
that run on a major landfill in the
unincorporated place of
success and it's way up there and a lot
of outof State trash as well as trash
from various locations in Coos County go
there and it
is has enough space to be
permitted uh for a long time in in the
future it's a huge
Enterprise in order to have
manufacturing because we still do have
one paper mill in
gorum and I think people still hope that
there will be Manufacturing in the
future you do need to have
landfills uh I think we
all regret that we don't do more
Recycling and
reuse and reduction
of materials but there is a very
substantial
landfill in Coos County in success and
it's run by the city of Berlin and all
these little towns each member each Town
member of city has one vote so it it's
really kind of an example of how
municipalities got together to do an a
commercial but not for profit
uh
landfill thank you
[Music]
representative representative B another
question yes I do thanks for taking my
question and thank you again represent
Tucker for for taking my question um you
mentioned that there's a landfill in
Success New Hampshire I think that's
Mount carbury if I'm not mistaken how
did this Bill affect mount
carbury it doesn't affect Mount cury and
this is one of the reasons you'll see
that uh representative laflam and
representative um hatch are
co-sponsors uh because one is from
Berlin and one is from gorm and there
was concern last year
because the bill last year mentioned the
Appalachian Trail and although you would
never know it if you went to mount
carbury which I have taken the grand
tour a couple of times uh but not that
far behind Mount carbury up uh
Topography is
um is the appalation trail and because
of the topography you would never
realize that one was as close to the
other and people uh who worry about
permitting for the future were concerned
about last year's
bill and I was a little concerned
because I think if you don't need to
involve Federal entities it's better not
to because it makes it more difficult so
this year's Bill only mentions the state
does not try to take in Appalachian
Trail does not try to take in the White
Mountain National
Forest uh that makes a lot more
complicated
Arrangements thank you
representative any other questions for
representative
Tucker I see one all right
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Tucker for for
taking my question so I I I understand
the intent of the bill but as I listen
to your testimony it seems that the
intent is to protect private business in
the North Country right so we're going
to protect the state park so that we
continue to attract tourists to engage
in Commerce and support local
businesses so I guess the the question
is why doesn't the bill include
protections for existing private
businesses in the North Country so if I
if I owned and operated a hotel or a
motel in North Country and the landfill
got permitted next door to my business
um you know I I could I'm sympathetic to
your your argument that that could be
detrimental if not disastrous to my
business so why is there no protection
in the bill for uh local businesses or
or even private
homeowners well I think that
traditionally uh those kinds of
protections have come through zoning or
land regulation
ordinances um Dalton has not chosen
until recently to go that particular
route each town of course or city has
the opportunity to adopt within a
framework um land protection Dalton did
not choose to do that
and uh so Whitefield is the next town to
it and they have uh the state park
and I think it would be unfortunate
to have that Park degraded and it really
seemed to be the only way that that kind
of protection could happen the omn Mount
Washington over the years has assisted
in or organizing protections for their
viewshed uh lots of additions to the
White Mountain National Forest so that
those kind of protections could happen
so I think the general protection of
businesses and Residences are done on a
Town by town city by City
basis I think pretty much through New
England through through zoning
ordinances so I don't think it's that we
aren't people aren't doing that if they
live in a town where there is protection
but I think this is a separate
problem maybe I'm not being articulate
about
that yeah follow up if I may Mr chairman
go
ahead yeah so so I understand your your
answer and I I tend to agree that these
these types of things are supposed to be
um addressed by by local zoning
ordinances if a community chooses so I I
guess we're we're looking at a bill
that's
imposing one Community zoning onto
another Community that's chosen not to
do the zoning but that's that's not my
my question my my question
is and I have to admit I haven't I
haven't I haven't walked the site but
say that
the yeah I have not so you say that the
Appalachian Trail is close to you know
another landfill but you would never
know the proximity so I guess could you
explain to me how it is that the
proximal location of the landfill um
would degrade the the state park
property that apparently is essentially
not developed at this point uh and and
how that couldn't be uh mitigated with u
you know a green zone a buffer a barrier
uh you know of green which is uh quite
common in Forestry applications where
they clearcut near a road they'll leave
20 ft of trees between the road and the
clearcut so that it's not obvious from
the
road yes the well the the size of Mount
carbur is I I can't remember how many
acres is is just absolutely enormous and
the Appalachian Trail is much higher and
uh is heading towards I can't remember
whether it's actually in Maine or just
about in Maine where would be uh not all
that far from success it's really a much
Wilder area and much greater topography
differences in uh at success the way uh
Forest Lake works it's it's not that
deep a lake and the
surrounding
Hills uh aren't that high so it really
would uh there is someone who has put
together some
photoshopped uh photographs that show
how the landfill if developed would
actually impact the lake and he may be
uh testifying this afternoon I don't
know but someone has actually done that
work and the it's not
that much difference in
elevation so that it actually would from
this Shallow
Lake where the land fillers proposed
would definitely show and the trucks and
the trucking and the noise and the
scavenger
animals um which are a lot of birds that
come to
U
landfills
at some of some of these landfills
actually hire people to shoot guns off
to make noise to scatter those
birds
um landfills now are covered every
afternoon or evening so that they don't
still have the be populations that
people used to have at smaller back when
we had dumps and uh but I think that at
farest Lake there's no question that the
surrounding areas that would be
developed into a landfill would affect
what happens at the park itself what
kind of Park experience you would
actually
have thank you representative Tucker I
appreciate it I'll be sure to visit the
uh the site this weekend thank you Mr
chair
question thank
you chair and thank you represent Tucker
for taking my question um we just talked
a little bit about the appalation trail
I've never hyped it myself um believe or
not um but I I imagine that and correct
me if I'm wrong hiking on a trail like
that especially the Appalachian Trail
where you're kind of traversing a larger
area um that might be something where
you would
walk by the area that's kind of affected
by mount carbury in a relatively short
amount of time as you're moving down the
trail whereas a state park that that
might be someplace you'd spend several
hours whole day at you say that's
probably correct yeah maybe I haven't
describ I've actually never
walked the that's part of the the mousk
section which is supposed to be one of
the most U difficult sections on the
Appalachian Trail it's rugged and uh
eventually it gets into Boulders where
there sort of like lemon squeezer
Boulders um I'm afraid my hiking days
are lower elevation ones today I have
hiked on the presidential range on the
Appalachian
Trail uh but I have never done a through
hike I might say our governor has um
but there is no no there is no
relationship
between the mount carbury and the actual
Appalachian Trail and it has buffers on
either side of it it's just that the
amount of miles that was in last year's
Bill did would could have affected they
felt the permitting because
they bought so much land to have prot
ction all around the landfills itself
that the people who were involved with
Mount carbury felt it had the potential
to be a problem but there is when you
walk the Appalachian Trail through the
musix you're totally unaware of Mount
carbury thank you representative any
Tucker
St thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question uh I did a Google oversight
look at uh the Forest Lake State Park
do and uh it looks like there's Park is
about 397 Acres that's
correct I'm trying to figure where the
perspective landfill was supposed to go
in how many acres east west north south
can can you give us a description of um
where the landfill was to be positioned
relative to the
park uh I I couldn't be the one to do
that I'm sure there is someone who could
who uh
because they they do have a place it's
in the town of
Dalton and as you see part of the lake
is in Whitefield and part of the lake is
in
Dalton
um so I I cannot answer that perhaps
there'll be another person who
can if not I can certainly arrange to
have the answer to that question sent to
you thank you committee did you have a
follow up or because I think that the
point I'd like to make on the answer
although I will get you the details is I
think that people came to realize that
this is something that should apply to
every state Park and not specifically
just to this one that the idea that of
all the places you could have a landfill
in New Hampshire you would have it next
to a state park where people have
invested uh
capital in and then
infrastructure for recreational
purposes
is just doesn't really make sense and
so I although I've seen the maps I've
seen the I I'm not able to describe it
uh
properly but I think that we need to
move past just Forest Lake and think
about other parks that we know and
love uh there's one in Goram that I walk
in uh moose Brook State Park
and you know there are a lot of
lot of parks around
that I think would want this
protection thank you representa any
additional questions for representative
Tucker you've been very generous with
your
time thank you representative we
appreciate your testimony thank you very
much for having
me all right so we have 25 additional
speakers signed up
and two more hours roughly that I've
allotted for the hearing so I think what
we're going to have to do is is ask
everyone to try andit themselves to a
voluntary thre minute uh time on their
speech I'm going to leave it voluntary
right this minute and we'll get through
a few speakers and see how well we all
do if we're not doing well adhering to
it I'm going to have to make it a
mandatory three minutes because we're
going to be uh running really long if we
don't so let's all uh try and be
respectful of everyone's time and the
fact that there's several more people
coming behind you so what I'll ask of
everyone that I bring up I just need to
to state your name I'll introduce your
name just state where you uh where
you're calling from the state that you
live in so that we can uh the committee
can know where you're coming from I'll
do my best to uh get through the list
I'm trying to pick through and kind of
go every other person as I can I put a
couple of folks up in the first three or
four slots that are going to I know
we're going to present a lot of good
technical information that I think will
help the committee to ask better
questions of the people people that
testify
behind so I'm next I'm going to call Tim
Associates Kim you hear us hello can you
hear
me uh hello my name is Tim White um
calling from Vermont and uh I would want
to thank the committee for the
opportunity to provide information to uh
to them regarding the proposed Granite
State landfill project as it relates to
House Bill
177 I'm a hydrogeologist with sorn
headen Associates and we're an
engineering and geosciences consulting
firm based in conquer I'm the Project
Director for the hydrogeologic
investigation at the proposed Granite
State landfill and yesterday I submitted
a letter to the committee summarizing
some of the key findings from the
hydrogeologic studies that have been
performed at the site over the past
several years including an assessment of
the groundwater and surface water flow
directions the findings from the
investigation indicate the site meets
the criteria that are contained in the
state of New Hampshire geologic sighting
limitations and that the site's
amendable for monitoring under a release
detection permit our hydrogeologic
report will be an attachment to the
forthcoming standard application for
Solid Waste landfill
and we're currently in the process of
preparing a separate release detection
permit application which will be
submitted to Dees for
review today I wanted to follow on my
letter to make myself available to
committee members to answer questions
they may have regarding groundwater and
site
did we l
you no I'm still here I I I just wanted
to make myself available uh if committee
members uh had questions uh regarding
groundwater and surface water at the
proposed project site I'm sorry I guess
I writing that sound like we lost you uh
does the committee any other the
committee have questions for Mr
White
stable thank you Mr chair thank for
taking my question um my question to the
previous speaker was how many acres the
proposed landfill is to be uh adjacent
to the Forest Lake State Park and how is
it situated relative to the park in the
lake is it Northeast south or west can
you give us some
idea yes I think some of the um speakers
following me can give some additional
details as it's proposed uh the proposed
landfill is approximately 137 acres and
it's situated west of Forest Lake State
Lake go ahead situated West that's
helpful how how far west would you say
relative to Forest Lake as a focal point
um would the line the demarcation line
be between the park and the adjacent
landf so the uh between the proposed
site and Forest Lake there is a
topographic Ridge that forms a surface
water divide between the two and water
east of that divide flows towards Forest
Lake and west of that divide flows
towards Alder Brook which is a tributary
to the amusic river and so the landfill
is west of that surface water divide I
believe it's approximately a half a mile
and I think I we can confirm that uh
that distance with some of the design
Engineers today that'll be speaking
thank you thank you representative
question am looking at the
that it appears to me that the
groundwater flow is away from Forest
Lake and away from the state park so um
because of that topographic Ridge so so
in your professional opinion do you
foresee any way in which uh groundwater
would be contaminated going to Forest
Lake or to the state
park uh so that's a that's a good
question U there the topographic divide
that that forms a surface water divide
has a related and underlying groundwater
divide along those topographically
higher areas and so the same just like
surface water is divided groundwater is
also divided and flows east of that
divide flows to Forest Lake West of the
divide it flows to Alder Brook and so uh
groundwater cannot go above and over
that divide it has to flow from from
higher elevation groundwater to lower
elevation groundwater can't flow in
reverse and in terms of contamination
the uh the solid waste Engineers will
discuss this uh today but the the
landfill will be designed with a double
liner system to contain the the waste
environment thank you any additional
vvin thank you Mr chairman uh and thank
you Mr White for taking the question um
so would I am I correct in assuming that
this facility is north of Route 116
east of mantis Hill Drive and
approximately west of Douglas Drive is
it in that general plot of land where
the landfill would be located that is
correct it's it's actually accessed by
Douglas Drive um off of Route north of
Route
116 excellent thank you Mr White thank
you Mr
chairman representative
dick yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um so uh you've
testified that uh it is um unlikely that
there are going to be uh groundwater or
surface water impacts from the uh from
the land from a potential landfill there
uh on Forest Lake itself uh but does
that mean that there would not be any
sort of environmental impacts on Forest
Lake or is it just the ones just the
just the that particular aspect of
hydrology that you don't see any impact
for the areas that I studi groundwater
and surface water um and we looked at
this closely including areas around uh
the proposed landfill uh so my focus is
on groundwater and surface water and
that's correct we we uh see that the
site is separated from the Forest Lake
water you a power or you offet
representative I'm all set
[Music]
verbil thank you Mr chairman um thank
thank you for taking the question Mr
White so I just want to make sure I'm
I'm clear based on what I've heard
before and what I'm hearing now so it's
my understanding looking at the maps
that the road access to the lake um any
road access to that lake is is a
separate road than would be the road
used to access the landfill from Route
116 that that's factually correct
right uh that is that is correct the the
site and the the property where the
landfill is proposed is access from
Douglas Drive and it's my understanding
that that does not connect vehicular
access to force lake so that Force Lake
would be accessed by other
roads thank you Mr White thank you Mr
chairman any additional questions
representative thank you Mr chairman and
uh thank you Mr White for taking my
question um I I went through your letter
and I I heard your testimony and it it
sounds like it makes some assertions
about the groundwater divide and
topographic in in the proposed site but
all that info seems to be specific to
this particular project
um but that doesn't speak at all to the
general proposed policy based topic uh
that HP
177 uh contains which is creating a two-
mile buffer around the state parks am I
right about
that uh that's correct I'm I'm not a
public policy expert so I what I did was
I focused uh my information for the
committee on the areas that I was uh
qualified to comment on the groundwater
additional
John
Mr SW are you able to
[Music]
again can you hear me okay all right we
get you now go ahead sir thank you very
much for taking my testimony today um I
did want to remind the committee that
the the house bill 177 that you're
considering today takes into account all
New Hampshire state parks not just the
Forest Lake battle that we're uh engaged
in currently um let's get to the point
of what we're talking about here we're
talking about a garbage landfill being
cited next to one of the most valuable
economic engines for the State of New
Hampshire our state parks and our Great
Outdoors so I hope that's not lost on
the committee I understand the line of
questioning and obviously the Forest
Lake situation is at the heart of this
bill currently but let's say in 20 30
year years from now when the turnkey
landfill is closed in Rochester and
Waste Management needs a new spot what
state park could possibly be considered
then and as far as the groundwater at
Forest Lake the the developer the
applicant has already admitted that and
I've sent photographs to the uh drawings
to the committee that this landfill
which will take in 18.4 million tons of
trash possibly half of it from out of
state uh it will be buried in a mountain
that ultimately will be visible from the
water at Forest Lake so in 30 years from
now when there is a mountain of toxic
trash Left Behind do you think visitors
or and tourists are going want go going
to want to go to Forest Lake State Park
and as for groundwater
contamination my fear is atmospheric
deposition I don't know if you're
familiar with that term but uh the waste
industry cites it
uh that we're talking about atmospheric
contamination I don't know if you're
aware but this past summer forest lake
suffered its first shutdown because of
the cyano bacteria that was an overload
of nutrients um to the lake it's a very
fragile Lake and Atmospheric deposition
from the landfill and the landfill by
the way is upwind of the lake and the
state park and we're talking landfill
gases obviously odor and right now
there's two class action suits in
Pennsylvania and New York relative to
landfill odor 2.5 miles away and five
miles away so atmospheric deposition of
odor harmful harmful landfill gases feal
contamination from seagulls and turkey
vultures will have a dramatic impact on
the water quality of forest lake at
Forest Lake State Park and it is the
only public beach in the vicinity where
res residents of the area and tourists
can come and access both the lake from a
beach and a public boat launch so if
this if this one landfill is s permitted
at Forest Lake I guarantee you that in
30 years this Lake will be lost I
guarantee you because it is already
identified by the EPA as an impaired
body of water due to the loading of
pollutants particularly Mercury which is
deposited via acid rain acid rain
atmospheric deposition and let's also
consider the impact of 100 plus trucks
going two and four from that facility a
day that's a 100 trucks imagine the
amount of dust that will be kicked up by
those trucks and the landfilling
operations which will blow in the
direction of the state park so um again
I just want to stress to the Comm
committee the importance of all of our
state parks and we're talking about a
landfill we're not talking about dollar
stores we're not talking about Walmart
we're talking about a garbage landfill
being sighted next to a state park and
two miles is not a uh a sacrifice it is
a compromise to protect the Integrity of
our state park system from a project
that no one would think has ever come to
fruition and here we are in the
permitting process so thank you for
listening to me I'll certainly take any
questions thank you Mr Swan is there any
questions Mr
Swan representative thank you thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Swan for
taking my question um you mentioned
seagulls um I I've visited some hiking
trails adjacent to the turnkey landfill
and when I was there I noticed what what
honestly had to be I mean absolutely
countless seagull I I obviously couldn't
count them but I would imagine thousands
to tens of thousands of
Seagal is that there were swarming over
the landfill is that kind of what you're
talking about and um if so what kind of
effect do you think that would have on
Forest
Lake well thank you for the question and
I will say currently at Forest Lake
State Park we have been at war with a
family of about five geese because they
like to hang out at the public beach so
we have a coyote decoy set up to try and
scare them away because just the fact
that those five geese are defecating in
the water it has we have had um um not
shutdowns but we have had concerns
relative to a higher feal count as a as
a result so imagine hundreds of Seagulls
coming not only defecating but at the
same time they're going to pose a
significant threat to our very at and
precious Lon population at the
Ville yes thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Mr Swan for taking the question I
don't know if you have the answer and if
you you don't perhaps somebody that
follows you uh may have the question do
you have the number of uh non-local area
visitors to Forest Lake State Park on an
annual
basis I don't actually have those
numbers because since it is a free park
we don't there's no collecting of funds
at the gate um I will tell you that
during the Fourth of July weekend the
parking lot which is a very large
parking lot was packed and I will say
that about probably a half of the cars
that were there were out of state and I
will also say that because of the covid
EP epidemic uh the state parks uh did
not open Forest Lake State Park and we
we rounded up volunteers we took care of
the park we opened it cleaned the uh
bathrooms and we made sure it was open
but I will tell you because of the covid
epidemic we've seen that more and more
people are flocking to the outdoors and
it would just be a travesty to lose one
of our state parks because of a
development project like this that could
be a threat to any state Park so the
value to our state economy from these
natural beauties needs to be
protected thank you followup if I could
Mr chairman follow up go
ahead yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh Mr Swan for taking the followup
so I I agree the the bill is written
broadly to protect all state parks but
uh by virtually everybody's admission
the the driver the intent is to um
derail a project that is already in the
permitting process um and so while I
would be more sympathetic to a bill like
this um if there wasn't an ongoing
project that that's already been begun
but I guess my question to you is do you
do you believe that it's it's fair to
the people that have invested time money
to buy the real estate and um are
following the existing permitting
project to um change the rules mid game
uh on on their Investments and their
business
decisions that's that's a great question
I'm glad you brought it up because first
off last year we presented House Bill
1319 and that was before any permits
were submitted also I'd like to point
out because I know zoning was brought up
the town of Dalton in July July 30th
2019 voted to enact emergency temporary
zoning in an effort to stop this project
zoning was very unpopular in Dalton
which Embraces Live Free or Die but we
passed it 154 to 129 in order to stop
this landfill development that has been
forced upon us because we had no zoning
they admit that in the process in the in
the in the U meetings with New Hampshire
Dees that Dalton had no zoning which is
one of the criteria for citing it there
and we voted to stop it so in essence
right now you by by helping us with this
bill to protect New Hampshire state
parks you would also be following the
will of the the people of the town of
Dalton who voted in emergency temporary
zoning and to this date cassella Waste
Systems the applicant has not submitted
an application to the town to seek local
approval for its development project so
if you ask me the cart is before the
horse relative to this project because
local satisfaction has not been met and
we have been harassed by this developer
because we're a small poor rural town
but we saw overall that if this could
happen
in Dalton at Forest Lake State Park it
could happen at any of your beloved
state parks in New Hampshire and we'
have also taken forth efforts to look at
ways to reduce waste and to as you've
said recycle Reduce Reuse and we realize
that mount carbury in uh Success New
Hampshire exists and has plenty of
existing capacity for New Hampshire
waste so thank
you thank you Mr Swan thank you Mr Mr
chairman before I call the next one Mr
Swan I'll just remind you that we are a
little tight on time so let's just try
and keep our answers brief and and
direct to the question thank you I
appreciate that I I apologize I I'm just
I love Forest Lake State Park and we
moved to New Hampshire six years ago we
love we love this great state and we
want to protect it understood sir
representative Kaplan did you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question and thank you Mr
Swanson um I don't think your your your
questions are out of line your answers
are out of line at all I appreciate your
passion Mr Swanson I'm concerned about
the rights of uh private land owners
specifically around the area Forest Lake
and the fact that they've been using
that Lake as an amenity for Generations
in some cases uh can you go into more
detail about the court cases you
mentioned in Pennsylvania and New York
about uh odor and I'm concerned about
the liability that we could be uh
looking at in terms of uh this this
build well currently around the Forest
Lake area there's 136 homes or
residences all people who either live
here or second homes but they are
taxpayers um in New York at the Ontario
County landfill which is operated by um
the same applicant we're talking about
uh there was a class action suit filed
for landfill odor from up to five miles
away um they even created a local um uh
iPhone app to report landfill odor it's
called it stinks. org you can check it
out um but it's a thousand a thousand
people class action suit filed in New
York state in uh 2020 uh the um um I
sent a link to the committee relative to
the Pennsylvania case um that cited um
an odor nuisance of up to 2.5 miles so
again this landfill footprint is only
it's actually there's parts of it that's
only 75 feet from the forest of the
state park and it's by my by my
estimates about 3,000 feet from The
Waters Edge of forest lake and in the
direction of prevailing winds so we're
trash follow-up question if I may who
who was uh who was the uh uh who was the
defendant in those who who was the
defendant in those
cases um the Pennsylvania case I can't
remember I only read the article once uh
Ontario County it is um uh the owner of
the facility is Ontario County and the
operator is cassella was
systems thank
you any further questions from Mr
Swan seeing none thank you sir for your
testimony thank
uh
can you hear me uh Mr chairman can Brian
go ahead okay thank you Mr chairman and
good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Brian G and I am
a lawyer with Cleveland Waters and bass
in
conquered I have had the privilege of
representing the New Hampshire
subsidiaries of cassella Waste Systems
for close to 30
years um I'd like to begin with some
sort of sobering statistics to put this
bill into context and these statistics
are derived from some an analysis we
just performed for cassella in
connection with the um very voluminous
uh application that will be filed in the
next day or so to permit this facility
with
Dees de's most recent projection for the
next 20 years beginning in
2022 is that the average per capita
waste generation rate in New Hampshire
will be 1.45 tons per year that amounts
to over 40 million tons of trash to
manage over the next 20 years based on
experiential data Dees assumes a 25%
recycling rate which means that over 30
million tons T of waste will require
disposal now depending on how you
measure it New Hampshire has between 7
and a half and 21.5 million tons of
disposal capacity over the 20 years
beginning in
2022 so even if all of the state's
disposal capacity were dedicated to
waste generated in New Hampshire we are
looking at a short fall of between 9
million and 23 million tons over the
same period and not that I what I said
is if all of the New Hampshire capacity
is used only to take New Hampshire
waste prior speaker uh alluded to the
fact though that waste from out of state
is imported into the
state that is to the tune of about a
million it's over a million tons a year
about 80% of that goes to the turnkey
landfill in
Rochester taking those Imports into
account that would increase the the
shortfall to over 20 million
tons now in accordance with statute Dees
limits the amount of waste that
commercial landfills and there are three
can accept each year every such landfill
in the state is now taking its maximum
annual amount so if the capacity at the
existing Bethlehem landfill is not
replaced the other facilities in the
state cannot take up that slack which
means that the businesses municipalities
and residents who now send their ways to
Bethlehem will have to find an out ofate
facility to accept their waste even if
they can do that they will have to pay
substantially more for
disposal um I just like to remind this
committee that in RSA 149 M many years
ago now uh the legislature said the
following I'm quoting it is responsible
meaning the legislature is responsible
to provide for the solid waste man needs
of the state and its citizens that's in
RSA 149
m11a it has also found and declared in
the same statute that quote in order to
provide for these needs it must ensure
that adequate capacity exists within the
state to accommodate the solid waste
generated within the borders of the
state even under the most optimistic
projections of the depletion of
permitted capacity New Hampshire will
not have enough capacity to accommodate
instate waste generation beginning in
2030 at the
latest if the legislature has any hope
of keeping its commitment to the people
of New Hampshire it is going to have to
find ways to bring more disposal
capacity online in the immediate future
house bill 177 would represent a breach
of that
commitment there one other point
briefly
um House Bill 177 is also of doubtful
constitutionality under the Bill's
language a landfill may be placed within
two miles of a state park if it is on
land owned by the state or any
municipality if the land is owned by a
private party however the same landfill
identical in every way is prohibited
there is no rational basis for this
discrimination because there's no
factual basis to conclude that landfills
on state or municipally owned lands have
any impacts on nearby property that
differ from the impacts of the same
landfill on privately owned land when a
land use is allowed or prohibited based
on who owns the property and not on the
characteristics of the use there's a
presumptive equal protection
violation that is not a surprising
outcome when legislation targets a
single project person or company like
House Bill 177
does um the committee should also be
aware that under de's rules uh there is
a requirement for a 100 foot setback
between any landfill and an adjoining
property and 500 feet between the
landfill and any property that has a
residence on it or a zoned residential
and you can find that in the code of
80404 so if this bill were to come law
it would be permissible to site a new
landfill 500 ft from a residential
neighborhood but impermissible to site
it within two miles of a state park
where no one lives and only visitors are
present I can think of no valid
scientific reason that uninhabited
Woodland requires a greater setback than
year round New Hampshire residents
require for their homes unless the
committee can think of such a reason I
submit that house bill
177 should be found inexpedient to
you will you accept some questions
yes questions Mr representative uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr Gold
for taking my question um a large part
of your testimony centered on capacity
concerns in the state of New Hampshire I
no there some opinions on on
the uh and what we should do about it
but my question is have we have we run
out of potential landfill sites in in
New Hampshire are state parks really the
only remaining land available for in and
trash there is a very rigorous process
that Dees requires someone to
follow uh to determine whether a a site
is in fact suitable
the fact that it is near a state park or
not near a state park isn't as important
as the
characteristics
because the the characteristics of the
land tell you how groundwater will move
how stable the facility will be how
accessible it will be and so forth under
Wetlands permitting it's incumbent on
the applicant to demonstrate that it has
attempted to find uh facilities not or
or locations not only in the state of
New Hampshire but in surrounding
states that will fill the need for
disposal
capacity so that that is a very very
broad inquiry that Dees undertakes and
if there's a a place in
Massachusetts that could be permitted
and that the applicant uh has not
considered the wetlands application
could theoretically be denied so I guess
my answer to your question
is uh that is all taken into account in
the currently ongoing permitting uh for
this
facility follow
um um thank you for taking my followup
um you mentioned that there's a rigorous
process would that rigorous process tend
to protect residential areas that you
mentioned you were concerned about as
you stated
earlier that's an interesting question
um you've got uh uh the Four Hills
landfill in nashaa within two miles of
that our count was Residential
Properties you've got the Lebanon
landfill in Lebanon and within two miles
of that you've got a an you know the
interstate you've got
um you've got the uh West Le
commercial district there um within two
miles of the carbury landfill is
virtually the entire city of
Berlin um so the way I would look at it
is if Dees is only requiring a 100 foot
setback or a 500 foot setback from
residential property that tells you how
successful the environmental permitting
regime has been
because the landfills are simply not
having significant on offsite impacts if
they were the setback would be greater
and those those setbacks
are
science-based they aren't just
arbitrary so I I it's helpful to dig
into the the details of the regulatory
scheme to better
understand uh what the what level of
ver thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Gold um I have I have two quick
questions uh for you the first one I
don't know if you you can or would want
to to answer I'm not a lawyer so I don't
I don't know the the legal aspects that
revolve around it but if you can answer
it I'd appreciate it is it your opinion
that if this
bill was enacted into law that it would
likely be challenged in court and also
likely to be struck down based on equal
protection
issues I have not spoken
to uh my client about that and of course
because of privilege even if I had I
couldn't disclose what we discussed but
I can
say um kind of relating back to what
what um I think it was you said earlier
that is we have a regulatory process in
place um the the purchase of this
property has been uh you know has took
place a long time ago the arrangements
took place years ago now and so here we
are years into the process and then this
bill comes along and and pulls the
plug would that result in litigation we
would have to take a very hard look at
that I I'm not prepared to say one way
or the other here today but as I said in
my in my
comments if the state tries to regulate
a land use based on who is doing it as
opposed to what the land use is it
raises a very sub and you can you can
you can imagine why it raises some very
very substantial constitutional
issues thank you Mr G uh quick followup
if I could Mr chairman sure follow up
thank you uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr G for the second question so I
live in Deerfield New Hampshire and um
we have a a capped a closed uh landfill
in our in our town and that uh that
landfill is monitored
extensively um for uh groundwater
contamination off the site uh as well as
off gassing you know up through the up
through the soils that were put down to
uh to cap that landfill uh is it safe to
assume that um this project has built
into it um all the modern and required
monitoring of the surrounding area to
make sure that um if any leeching was to
occur it would be uh identified and
corrected rapidly and before it it
became a major problem is that a is that
a relatively safe assessment it is and
um Mr White the hydrogeologist referred
to this in his comments um that is
release detection Wells um once you
figured out which direction groundwater
flows they put one well what's called
upgradient so on the high side of the
flow flow area and then a series of
Wells uh outside of the landfill downg
gradient so you know what the
groundwater is going in to the area
where the Line Landfill is and then you
assess whether there are any
contaminants in the groundwater below
and the assumption is that if there is
contamination there that isn't in the
upgradient well that you have some kind
of a release from the
landfill um so yes that is required by
uh by Dees regulation and by
Statute thank you Mr G thank you Mr
SES thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Gold for taking my question and I
want to try to swing the um discussion a
little bit to the outof state
garbage
and I'm from Nashua and um we have the
Four Hills
landfill and um because it's a private
landfill old by the city of Nashville we
do not accept out of state garbage and
we have the the last time I heard which
was last year when our delegation
visited they have 40 more years of
capacity at the Four Hills
now
what what is the benefit to the state of
New
Hampshire to have out of state garbage
brought
here uh I'm not sure that that I can
answer that uh except in a very general
way representative and that is that um
these facilities because they are so um
so carefully designed to ensure no
release to the environment are very very
expensive uh millions and millions ions
of dollars go into construction of a
single
cell and um that has to be funded in
some in some
fashion um all of the private
landfills uh all of the commercial I'm
sorry commercial landfills in the state
so that would be carbury TurnKey and
ncees all of them take out of state
waste
because waste management is uh
vertically
integrated uh meaning that the the most
efficient and cost effective way to
manage waste is to capture it at the
curb to bring it to a transfer station
and then to haul it to wherever it's
going to be disposed of after
recyclables have been taken out so the
the the reason that comes to mind for me
at least I'm not going to pretend to be
an expert but the reason it comes to
mind is is it enables the companies
building these very expensive facilities
to meet their you know their Debt
Service and their internal rates of
return
followup
sure thank you Mr chairman Mr Gold then
who
benefits from the outof state garbage
and where does it come from how far away
garbage um you're getting a little
Beyond uh what what I know about I know
a lot of it comes from Massachusetts I
think quite a bit of it comes from
Maine um and I think those are the two U
heaviest contributors to out ofate waste
but like I said about 80% of that goes
to the turn key facility in Rochester
which is operated by Waste Management
Corporation and I don't I don't
represent waste management and I don't
have an intimate knowledge of where
those things come from what I can just
say on the cassella side is that where
it's
economically beneficial to the company
and its
customers to gather waste along certain
routes get them to transfer stations and
then efficiently get them to landfills
or to murfs materials recovery
facilities um they're going to they're
going to use those routs and if they
cross state lines they cross state lines
who
benefits I think everybody in New
Hampshire benefits from competition in
the waste disposal IND industry and from
keeping the uh the cost as low as
you
representative viby are you able to
unmute yes um thank you Mr chair uh I
have a somewhat more General legal
question which is uh in terms of the uh
Le the legal recourse that a private
land owner would have if the um if
someone if an abutter were to uh establ
um establish a use that was um
detrimental to the uh to his his or her
um businesses so uh for instance if um
if someone had a uh a business that
depended on uh the natural beauty of
their own land uh perhaps a
u kayaking business or something uh and
uh there was an abutter that uh
diminished the ability for that person
to get clientele by putting in something
next door that uh diminished the value
is there does that person have any legal
re
recourse yeah there's a there's a cause
of action uh known as nuisance I'm sure
you're uh generally familiar with it and
if the basic principle is that if
someone's use of land uh or or
operations on a piece of land are um
sufficiently harmful to the interests of
um nearby land owners then that that uh
can be enjoined an injunction can be
issued by a court preventing that
ongoing use or uh the the homeowner or
the business could recover damages for
that does um follow up yeah does do the
harm have to have already happened
before that before the person can uh sue
for on on a nuisance
basis yes okay so in this case if a if a
land owner was harmed by the landfill
they could only Sue after the landfill
established there would have to be harm
from from the use of the
property to that to that landfill I'm
sorry to that property
owner
um I suppose I'm just trying to think
through you know various hypotheticals
and I I don't think it would necessarily
just hypothetically be the case that the
landfill would have to be would have to
be there I think with any development
you know if you're Excavating and you
know as a result of the excavation you
cause some kind of off-site harm then
there's a potential for liability for
the excavation so um I don't think it's
the case that the landfill would
actually have to be in place it would
depend on what the nature of the claimed
harm
you
I I'm sorry I can't quite hear Mr chair
that's because I forgot to turn my mic
on sorry about that so I said I'm gon
allow one more question uh of the of the
witness because we have 22 more people
that want to testify so perhaps some of
your questions will get answered by
Future testimony so representative
Murray I'll recognize you for a question
thank you thank you Mr chair for taking
my question and thank you Mr Gold for
taking my question um is landfilling the
only waste disposal method available for
your
client the only waste
disposal uh Avenue open to my client yes
I see um once you have eliminated uh to
the extent it's technologically feasible
once you've eliminated the uh reusable
or recyclable portions of the waist
um really only two technologies right
now that are available one is um
incineration in some form and even that
the Ash has to be landfilled um or
landfilling very
much thank you all right I'm going to uh
I'm GNA ask that we move on to the next
I want to thank Mr goul for coming in
and answering all these questions
test thank you Mr chairman very welcome
so we have 22 more people to testify and
so far we've got four through in an hour
and a half so I'm really going to ask
people to please keep your your comments
down to three minutes or less and if
someone else is has testified and and
given the information you want to then
please summarize it as quickly as you
can and and let's see if we can move
along at a little quicker Pace I would
next work recognize Nina we from Save
Forest
Lake hello good everybody hear me yeah
go ahead okay hi uh I am writing to
submit my testimony and support of
hb77 I'm calling from Bethlehem New
Hampshire um this bill being passed is
not only essential but it is necessary
um it is home to hundreds of people but
we are also a huge tourism
destination um a highly concentrated
area full of toxins such as a landfill
needs to be treated as a waste site as
it is such this two mile radius would
act as a barrier and protect the highly
diverse and highly active ecosystems
that exist in and around these landfill
sites not only ground ecosystems but
water sources the amusic is a reservoir
that starts a few miles Upstream from a
massive landfill in Bethlehem New
Hampshire uh I am representing save
Forest Lake an organization in the uh
the home of the White Mountains of
Northern New Hampshire also home to the
threat of existing and projected
landfills that happen to be in my
hometown and the neighboring Town um I
am relieved to hear that a company is
doing the research on groundwater and
surface water and although the results
are up to standards currently I'd be
willing to bet I'd be willing to
guarantee that that will change once the
landfill begins development um in
Coventry Vermont Vermont's only running
landfill quote the state has found
elevated levels of pfas and leate tested
from closed landfills around the state
with Coventry the state's only open
landfill testing the highest end quote
that landfill is owned and managed by
cassella who also owns the existing
landfill in Bethlehem New Hampshire and
the proposed landfill in dalon New
Hampshire all of which neighbor bodies
of water um I will try to finish up um
we need to think and act in a
humanitarian way the White Mountains
have done their fair share of business
with privatized landfills over 25 years
in my hometown specifically and it is
not near slowing down and with that I
ask all of you to please support and
pass this bill today and all future
decisionmaking in regards to waste
management thank you for accepting my
testimony and thank you for your time
thank you Nia great job two minutes and
questions
thanks did you hear the question are you
clerk yes yeah I could email that um
email go on to h.gov go on to our
committee and that way you can email
your testimony everybody on there the
email commit and get testimony perfect
okay I can do that thank you you any
Nina all right thank you Nina thank you
all right next I will call on Joe Fusco
I pronounced your name
right
systems can you hear me Mr chairman yeah
go ahead thank you very much good
afternoon and again thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for giving me the time to share my
thoughts with you today I am Joseph
Fusco a vice president of castella way
systems we are a critical part of how
Society manages the life cycle of our
natural and material resources from
recycling to Renewal to disposal we
believe we have a social responsibility
to carefully and reasonably think about
invest in and develop the vital
infrastructure including landfills that
make Modern Life possible we believe it
is vital to develop this infrastructure
under a rigorous policy and Regulatory
framework that prioritizes science and
fact-based examination of many critical
factors including technology safety
hydrogeology and Relentless engineering
and operating standards we have
submitted written testimony to the
committee in opposition to this bill
first and foremost we believe this bill
is unnecessary from a regulatory
permitting and public policy
standpoint any technical scientific
environmental concerns or standards for
citing a landfill on any square inch of
New Hampshire land is covered and
addressed under a very sophisticated and
comprehensive Regulatory and permitting
regimen this regimen reviews hundreds of
criteria and requires the extensive
scientific review of multiple
environmental and quality of life
impacts in fact the protections that
proponents of of this bill seek are
covered by New Hampshire's Regulatory
and permitting standards and processes
the fears proponents seek to soothe with
this bill are superseded by an existing
public policy process containing an
immense amount of diligence on every
aspect of the appropriate sighting
permitting construction operation
closure and post-closure monitoring of
New Hampshire's landfills the simplest
argument against the bill is that it is
unnecessary it is not a scientific
fact-based approach to policymaking
around the management of New Hampshire's
environmental infrastructure it is the
inconsistent hypocritical targeting of a
specific industry a specific company and
a specific project it puts New
Hampshire's waste disposal
infrastructure at risk in the face of a
capacity shortfall in the next two
decades and threatens over $400 million
in direct economic impact to the state
this legislation is not how you manage a
vital public infrastructure we urge the
committee to oppose it also in addition
to me today you have heard or will hear
from other members of the cassella team
with various expertise inciting and
permitting I encourage you to use these
folks as a scientific fact baked
resource for your more technical
permitting and Regulatory process
questions on this issue thank you Mr
chairman
Fusco all right looks like you're all
set nice job right in the three minute
thank you all right next we will call up
Elliot wler
[Music]
from
chairman Pearl can you hear me can
please just state where you live and uh
go ahead and testify uh my name is
Elliot wesler I'm a resident of
Whitefield New Hampshire um is um I'm
speaking on behalf of ncbc which is one
of several um um Grassroots
organizations uh that uh are very
concerned uh about the uh cassella
proposal to build a new landfill in
Dalton um is uh we have provided letters
to each of the committee members uh I've
also uh provided written testimony and
I'm not going to repeat what's what's in
those two documents uh I would ask you
please to read them uh I understand that
uh you have been
blizzard uh by paper but we think there
are very important arguments uh that uh
our organization is making uh why this
is a good bill and why you should
support it um apparently Mr Fusco uh
believes that anyone who does not
support this bill is a hypocrite um he
has just so much as said so um is uh I
I'm not sure why um uh the
representatives from
Cella can't um uh provide
unbiased um um uh
testimony uh to this committee um is uh
with respect to the engineering and
other expertise that the um that Cella
can provide um our
organization um has hired um a
hydrogeologist um a Wetlands expert a
traffic engineer and has an attorney uh
that's advising us and uh um I would uh
uh um say to you that uh I believe our
experts are every bit as good and
presumably less biased uh than the
self-interest expert advice that you'll
get from from
Cilla um there's only
one um uh Point uh maybe two points uh
that I'd like to emphasize one is it
seems like there's two threshold
questions here one of them is is
legislation needed and uh my answer to
that question is yes it is um by de's
own admission uh they are sted
underresourced and frequently uh
outmanned and
outgunned by um um the uh applicants uh
who file uh for permits uh at
Dees is um this legislation is it seems
to me just pure common sense um is a TW
mile
buffer uh so that um landfill which is a
a
very very environmentally um um
dangerous uh land use uh should not be
located uh next to a state park uh state
parks are for the enjoyment of all of
the citizens I'll stop there I I want to
interrupt your your well past three
minutes can you wrap up in like 10 I
will stop there thank you very much I
appreciate it any questions from Mr
wesler okay go ahead um thank you Mr
chair my question um I I noticed that
we're asking everyone where they're from
I don't recall did we get where Mr Fusco
was
from he was representing fael Waste
Systems so the ones who uh are
representative of the companies I'm
aware of where they're from but when
they're myself I'm not aware of where
they are that's why I'm asking from that
used to be a criteria on the old blue
sheet if you
recall s do we know where C system from
I don't know where their headquarters is
no I'll ask the next represent thank you
any other questions from Mr wesler yes
go
ahead thank you Mr chair
um Mr wesler thank you for taking my
question you mentioned you've hired your
own
expertise people traffic engineer
hydris how about air quality water
migration have you got an expert uh HED
for that
specific uh we do not uh if uh the um
committee believes that uh uh you would
like to have some
unbiased um expert information in that
area is uh we would see what we could
do thank
you all right any further questions from
Mr
wesler
hands all right thank you sir appreciate
your
[Music]
repres thank you representative I'm
going to take one minute here just as a
caution to everyone that's coming
forward you got to remember that this is
a a forum for the committee to receive
critical info and let's be a little
careful about the dispar disparaging
comments about other testimonials I
understand it's an emotional issue and
I'm certainly not calling out anyone but
I just want to remind everyone going
forward excuse me to just just be a
little cautious so that everyone here
believes that they're uh you know doing
doing the right thing providing good
testimony so let's uh let's keep it
Ley I have next we are you on here Greg
under a phone number or
something can't find you by name if you
please right on come back to later on so
you able time oh there you go looks like
see the
Ros oh I'm sorry is that for Chris
Walker yes oh I I apologies it just went
offline here I'll try and keep my
comments to less than three minutes I
certainly appreciate the opportunity
here to speak to the house environment
and agricultural committee at the
hearing today so my name is Chris Walker
as I said I'm I'm a member of the public
although I live in situ Mass my family
has had a camp on Forest Lake for almost
50 years and I strongly encourage you to
look at the proposed site to see just
how close it is to the lake as well as
the park um you know I'm speaking as my
family's representative I won't go into
the history of this but with 50 years of
coming back and forth and owners of this
property uh as a second home but we also
function as tourist bringing a lot of
friends and families up there as well so
if you've been to Forest Lake you know
includes you know what You' hope to see
in in many of these beautiful properties
that you know the freshwater fish the
flocks of loons otter beavers snapping
turtles crayfish and we've recently even
had a bald eagle that is now nesting in
the area and whenever we have people
visit they're always taken back by the
beauty and serenity of this lake so I'm
speaking today in support of this um HB
177 which presents which prevents the
sighting of a Landfield near the state
park and although Forest Lake and its
state park is specific to our family I'm
sure many of you here today are having
their own concerns of New Hampshire
parks and how they may be impacted in
the future by installing these landfills
in near proximity unfortunately ours is
is a current and real world battle that
we're going through right now um you
know New Hampshire is a state that
relies heavily on tourism as
representative tuo touched on and we all
have seen that firsthand and should a
landfill be permitted I am sure the
eventual sight of the landfill the smell
and Airborne contaminants as the state
park would be downwind of the landfill
based on the prevailing winds coupled
with the thousands of garbage eating
scavengers and animals and seagull will
detour tourists and locals from visiting
Forest Lake State Park over the long run
having a long-term ripple effect on the
sustainability of keeping it open and
attracting people to the lake so in
closing um I I I do know for a fact that
I would not visit any park nor allow my
children to swim in a lake that borders
a landfill regardless of what these
hydrology reports May say and I would
suggest you pose the same questions to
yourselves now Al those states do need
these local landfills I don't see why
New Hampshire needs to put open up its
borders to haul in neighboring trash
sites but most importantly put them near
stream lakes and rivers which severely
impacts the state's most valuable
resources time and time again we hear of
pollution impacts of landfills and often
it comes from Impact areas in and around
rivers lakes which transports pollutions
and has more directly impacted human
populations we simply cannot let
corporate Waste Management firms
permanently impact or ultimately ruin
these natural reserves that have th
thrived for thousands of years to be
direct our family and many others on the
lake we have spoken with will likely
sell our homes of many many years should
this be put in putting further downward
pressure on the economy of these small
towns in conclusion supporting this is
not only the right thing for all of you
to do for the long-term sustainability
of the state parks it's the only thing
to do we must protect these Parks now
for the future enjoyment of generations
to come I thank you very much for your
time and
yes so uh just to be clear would it be
fair to say that um if a landfill were
built uh next to Forest Lake uh you and
your family and the guests you
frequently have would probably take your
tourist tolers
elsewhere absolutely I I I looking to
the longterm here and what this home has
meant to us as hard as that would be I
would sell this piece ofct property as
soon as we can to get out of there
before what we feel is going to be you
know a lasting impact on uh the lake
itself I I mean we're not only affecting
the state park here but we're affecting
the lake and as somebody touched on you
know there is a public boat launch so
it's not just the state park itself it's
everything in and around there this is
not a large lake it's probably a half
mile across by two miles wide maybe a
little bit more so we're not talking
about a massive Lake in which um you
know it's it's the impact of pollution
will be diluted over time but yes as
hard as that would be we would leave we
would leave the
area thank you any other questions for
Mr
Walker
ver thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Walker I appreciate the testimony uh
certainly you know the protection of
surface Waters is is critically
important so would you advise the
committee to amend this bill to um ban
landfills within two miles of open
surface water in the state of New
Hampshire absolutely you know time and
time again you read about these cases
and I'm no expert on this but when you
talk about how these pollutions get into
water systems the aquifers the streams
and the rivers and the impact on human
population you know that seems where
where a lot of this is spread and I'm
not saying we don't need or shouldn't
have I appreciate the statistics that
have been put forth about needing these
landfilled sites but why do they need to
be near state parks why do they need to
be near
water uh follow up if I may Mr uh
[Music]
chairman thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Walker so I I certainly haven't done
the full survey uh but I I would dare
guess that if the state of New Hampshire
were to ban um locating landfills within
two miles of open surface water that we
would never be able to site another
landfill in New Hampshire and so if that
was the case what would you propose that
New Hampshire do with its Solid
Waste well thank you for the question I
I am not an expert I mean that's a
pretty interesting statistic that
there's no piece of property that would
be within two miles of a stream um I
think that there's people out there that
are more versed in this and experts that
might be able to answer that apologies I
I don't have
one thank you Mr Walker thank you Mr
Walker all right see none thank you Mr
Walker we appreciate your testimony
thank you as
well next I will call up Samuel Nikolai
Systems good afternoon can you hear me
we can thank you coming in
sir thank you very much appreciate the
opportunity my name is Sam Nikolai I am
vice president of engineering for
cassella Waste uh to the earlier
question cassella is headquartered in
Rutland Vermont uh which is where my
office is we have about uh 15 different
facilities uh in New Hampshire and work
closely with communities in New
Hampshire up and down the state uh I am
particular am responsible for the
engineering for the company and I am a
licensed professional engineer in New
Hampshire you've already heard lots of
testimony and I certainly don't want to
cover um any of the ground we already
have um I will point out that this bill
is proposing what we call a sighting
criteria is a setback requirement from
the uh from a state park of two miles
the New Hampshire rules already contain
citing criteria and you've heard about a
few of them 500 feet from a residence
200 feet from a surface water body there
are others for airports for roads for
Wetlands uh there's a specific one for a
th000 feet from a drinking water intake
two miles is
10,560 Ft so that kind of puts into
perspective compared to all the existing
sighting criteria this bill would
establish a sighting criteria massively
larger than any of the other criteria
that are applicable to the existing
surface water bodies Rivers wetlands and
other features in New Hampshire as we
all are aware there's really no
technical basis for this the bill
focuses in on state parks not federal
ones not local parks it focuses on
privately owned properties not publicly
it's obvious ly only about one project
and it ignores any technical basis and
just simply promes a criteria meant to
end that particular project we've heard
lots of allegations of potential impacts
we've heard discussion of atmospheric
deposition and seagull feal matter and
dust control and I'm not sure that any
of those are of particular uh Focus here
but I would say regardless of any
impacts it is a landfills um uh import
obligation to be protective of all of
the surrounding areas whether or not
there's a state park we need to be
protective of groundwater whether or not
protective of traffic concerns odor
concerns whether the state park is
located within a mile or whether it's
located in five miles and those
obligations are already spelled out in
the rules and the regulations through
the the dees so to take this bill to
take a setting criteria out of uh that
normal process makes no techical
sense I would also say that the only
potential area that we have looked at
from a a state park impact that we
haven't already discussed is the view
and certainly we want to be cognizant of
the potential impacts to the view so
when we look at what could be the view
from forest uh Lake State Park to the
landfill we think that the lake is the
most important area because if you're on
a boat in the lake that's your best
opportunity need to have an unu A View
back to the landfill and when you look
back to the landfill from that Lake what
are you going to see for the first 24
years of the landfill's operation you
will see nothing the landfill is not
visible from the lake any part of the
lake for 24
years after that there will be a very
sliver of the landfill that will just
poke its head up above the trees and you
will see the very edge right above the
tree line for for about a year as we
operate the very top of the
landfill the waste will be covered the
soil will be placed and the grass will
be grow on the slopes and that Hill will
resemble any other Hill that you see in
the green areas of New Hampshire and
that will be limited to that one year of
operation so two and a half decades
you'll never see any impacts you've
already heard the testimony groundwater
and surface water physically cannot go
to the lake they go in the other
direction water cannot flow uphill both
surface water and groundwater will never
reach the lake we are very cognizant of
the lake and of the park in proximity to
our proposed project and they're taking
every step to ensure that Park and that
Lake are fully protected at every step
of the way thank you for the opportunity
thank you
sir uh so youve sever hands raised I'll
start with the representative
Perez yeah Mr chair um I just um have a
question because we I know that we
trying to keep up everyone um in under
three minutes and I just wonder if we
GNA keep continue doing that with
everyone well I've been allowing about a
30 second uh Beyond if they're seems
though they're wrapping up that's why I
try to interject about three minutes 30
seconds if they haven't done so so I'm
attempting to keep it Clos thank you uh
representative
Cath
yeah thank you Mr chair for taking my
question thank you Mr Nikolai for your
time um I'm glad to hear Mr Nikolai that
you uh agree that landfills need to take
every protection uh necessary um to
protect the immunities or the people
that surround it um as regards this
landfill uh or any landfill do landfill
experience so the landfill has a double
aligned system system cassella has never
had a release from a lined landfill
through a double line system we have
100% success have landfills that Cella
operates or others ever had compliance
issues sure we have we've had periods of
time where we've had to address odors or
deal with other issues but we've never
had a release from a landfill from a
line facility to
groundwater followup question if I
may um have you uh have you taken any
measures to mitigate odor emissions and
do you expect there to be any odor
emissions from this projected
landfill odor management is extremely
important uh it's primarily through our
landfill gas uh management both the
structures that we build within the
landfill as well as how we operate in
the last 10 years landfills in general
and Cassel in particular have been um
advancing in terms of our odor
management managing wastes such that we
can do so in a way that they do not
produce off-site odors we're certainly
aware um that uh waste is potentially
odor producing you know that if you
leave your trash in your can for too
long at the curb you know you have the
potential to produce odor so we take
steps to ensure that we bury waste as
quickly as we can and we manage all the
odors so that they are not causing
offsite impacts it's a critical part of
our operation and it's a critical focus
thank you representative
you
question mentioned that the lake in the
park was downwind of the landfill is
this
true so wind direction certainly changes
over time um there there are is the
potential that at some seasonal times
that the wind direction will be towards
uh the East which would be in the
general direction of the the lake and
the park um but the prevailing winds
will certainly move um our uh policies
and our systems are designed to ensure
that the other management is is handled
sort of regardless of the wind direction
we can't rely on wind to be a success we
need to manage the odors such that they
never leave our property and so
certainly you know that's part of our
evaluation and and I'm certainly not
going to say that the wind never moves
in that direction um but um that's
certainly is part of our Focus
H CH we're having trouble hearing again
okay
okay yes sir you decied at the 25e point
there'll be a bit of a sliver or few
top I'm sorry I couldn't hear the
question I heard the about the sliver in
regards to the view but I couldn't hear
the question itself do you have a Max
elevation that the landfill will be
allowed to
rise the uh there's not a maximum yet in
terms of uh the process I mean certainly
that would be as a result of the uh
overall permitting um the top of the
landfill we do expect to be slightly
higher than the ridge uh that is
adjacent to it however um from a
Viewpoint standpoint since an observer
is going to be looking up um that Ridge
that runs along the northeast part of
the landfill blocks The View from the
park and from the lake uh so we expect
that that's why even though the landfill
itself will be I want to say maybe in
the neighborhood of 50 feet or so higher
than the ridge that you will not have uh
impacts to those views except as I
described thank
you all right
representative Murray I guess there not
a
question
representative
thank you um Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Nikolai for taking my question um I
would like to just talk for a second
about um the odor
mitigation and um I was just wondering
if you could explain that process in
more
detail sure so our first line of defense
is to collect landfill gas um as
aggressively as we can so we use a
number of systems in order putting wells
in um putting horizontals in and putting
them in as early as we can landfill gas
which is the the generated from the
degradation of the material in the
landfill is uh first and foremost uh
what we're trying to prevent ever
leaving the site and we have a lot of
success in achieving um greater than 90%
of of collection of that gas which helps
to mitigate those odors there are other
um areas that we need to watch we need
to be concerned about the odor of any
particular vehicle as it comes into the
landfill so we have a focused program on
identifying any issues and working with
our customers and clients to make sure
that those kinds of odors don't occur
and then as a response we do odor
investigations where we send someone to
go evaluate an odor complaint if we
receive one where did it come from how
long did it last what kind of odor it
was so that we can go back and correct
any particular issues as always a
landfill is not the only source of voors
so we often find that we have odors from
manure placement or Wastewater
facilities or others and it's tough to
distinguish between them that's why we
use that investigation process to
quickly and clearly identify what that
concern is and address
it
followup yes go ahead thank you um would
is something that you would spray
aerosol to mask and
odor it is a tool that we can use we
don't like
the resorting to a mask um the preferred
method would be to um get it at its
source and never allow a potential odor
and so we've gotten very good at that
certainly trying to use an aerosol
either um we prefer a neutralizing agent
versus a masking agent but they can be
Tools in our toolbox especially for
sensitive areas but as a general rule we
want to prevent any odors from ever
happening thank
you thank you uh represent restive
vinsky yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Nikolai we talked a lot about
different types of pollution here but we
haven't I haven't heard a whole lot
about uh noise pollution uh we've been
looking at I'm looking at the map right
now and there's the lake is fairly
nearby the state park is or the the
forest is there um I'm assuming with
with the amount of trash that we're
talking about there's going to be
significant amounts of of noise
pollution for both those spots is that
is that correct and is there anything
that can be done to mitigate
that typically a landfill does not have
a significant amount of noise pollution
um the trucks themselves do not make a
lot of noise the one thing that we do
have to keep close tabs on are the
backup alarms on equipment so you all
are familiar if You' ever been by a
construction site you've heard the beep
beeping of a of a piece of equipment
moving backward um and so that's
probably the loudest type and so that's
often a focus and when we find that um
that is a concern and and the the the
conditions are are right for that noise
going a long way um there are ways to
replace those backup alarms with quieter
versions and we've often U been able to
do that if we had a particular concern
but in general because of the buffer
zones that a landfill is obligated to
have uh the noise is cut down uh quite a
good bit and we typically do not find
that's a a huge issue but we do have
some tools that are available to us if
if it becomes a particular issue or if
it's a particular of sensitive need to
the nearby
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Nikolai for taking my question um you
mentioned in your testimony that catella
has occasionally had issues with owns
for a short period of time um I'm
curious if Cella has ever faced any
administrative fines for environmental
infractions such as failing to store
sludge properly at a facility leaking
toxic chemical into nearby water
features or otherwise violating Solid
Waste Wetlands or Air Pollution Control
regulations so we operate in Six States
and we have an environmental record in
every state uh we're very proud of our
environmental record we believe that
we've operated a variety of facilities
for many decades and done so in an
exemplary manner have we had compliance
issues at sites we certainly have there
have been times in which we've struggled
at a particular facility for a short
period of time to address a particular
issue we've had challenging waste
materials that have taken us some time
to address and so all of those um
short-term issues are things that we
take very seriously and that we address
to answer your question have we had
compliance issues yes we have have we
ever paid a fine in States yes we have
in every case we investigate and we
remediate and we learn from that so that
issue doesn't happen again we're
particularly sensitive as we should be
to protection of surface water and
drinking water that's our our biggest uh
concern we want to make sure that we
never have any kind of release to
drinking water or surface water and so
I'm very proud that our company has an
excellent record especially in that
facilities thank you representative
Bixby yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Mr Nikolai um I
live about um five miles or so down the
kico Valley from the turnkey landfill
and in certain atmospheric conditions
particularly when there's uh sort of
low-lying fog uh I smell the turnkey
TurnKey landfill and I'm wondering if
that if you have a mechanism that is
substantially better than waste
managements to d uh deal with
odors we certainly use similar type
strategies um our existing landfill in
Bethlehem as well as proposed land Phil
uh in Dalton are a good bit smaller than
the turnkey facility so the turnkey is a
very very large facility they also take
by far the the largest percentage of out
ofate waste and some of the most
challenging waste from other states and
so I would submit that TurnKey has its
own particular challenges with its
facility and its size as well as kind of
where it's located uh we certainly use
similar strategies but we believe that
our strategies are very effective and we
believe our record at Bethlehem shows
from an odor standpoint that they are
very effective again have we ever had
periods of time where we've had concerns
yes we have but we've addressed them and
we've moved uh ensure that that does not
repeat uh I think we're are working on
well over a year I don't want to say the
wrong number here but I think it's close
to a year since we've had a notary
complaint at our Bethlehem landfill we
think that's an excellent record and we
look forward to continuing that
thank you uh representative Murray has a
question uh yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr Nikolai for taking my
question just can we Circle back for a a
brief moment back to um gas collection
and um what is your specific method for
doing that once once once you have
obtained it where does it go after that
is my
question great question so uh we would
as much as possible we like to take that
gas and um uh use it to produce
renewable energy either through uh
combustion burning it in engines or
turbines and um then being able to sell
electricity to the Grid or converting
that gas to uh RNG renewable natural gas
um our plans for uh the granite state
landfill do include a component for um
this renewable energy we think it's very
likely that it will be an RNG facility
and so we have the opportunity once you
take that gas to convert it to power and
use it as a renewable source uh and that
as well um you know provides the the
offsets you from an emission standpoint
as well um so we think that'll be a very
valuable part of the proposed project
going forward um certainly we have
facilities that have a variety of
different mechanisms today um but by far
the most is we we have on-site engines
that uh combust the gas and sell it back
to the
grid thank
you thank you see no more hands and
questions in the room so Mr Nikolai
thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much next we have Sarah duet from the
change
are you able to hear me we can now yes
thank you um greetings and thanks for a
hearing testimony
today um I do have some prepared notes
which I've edited down but I want to say
just a couple notes um based on what
I've been hearing um
Dees certainly does have a critical
regulating process but to dat Dees is
not satisfied with the sighting search
that Cella has documented and in fact
they noted that Dees noted it in uh the
wetlands permit uh requests for more
information saying that they needed more
certainty that the site search had been
adequate in this case and also although
we've been hearing for two years that
water cannot flow uphill um again Dees
has indicated that there have not been
adequate groundwater studies done and
that it's not necessarily the case that
groundwater moves in ways that are
entirely unpredictable unless they've
been well studied and that has not
happened yet in this case so although
it's possible for these things to happen
um I think we have to be clear that just
saying they've happened doesn't mean
they happen and we all need to look at
the fine print uh in the conversations
that are going forward I would also say
I've lived um and visited the east side
of forest lake for over 50 years and the
prevailing wind is to the east right
over the lake from the site that's
proposed and you can just come and visit
and you'll know that most any
day uh and I get reports of um noise
complaints I got one this week from a
woman living a half mile from the site
in Bethlehem um truck loud truck backup
noises that disturb her outdoor life in
Sugar Hill so uh again just underscoring
the point there are a lot of experiences
to be considered here so in my own
comments um I live in Whitefield I've
worked for Environmental Protection as a
private citizen and with North Country
Alliance for balance change which
includes several hundred environmental
Advocates and the group is passionately
committed to the passage of this bill I
want to talk to you about stewardship my
stewardship and yours and that of
everyone who's rallying to support this
bill it is our responsibility to speak
for these places that we know are
irreplaceable people who defend the
environment and even our parks are
sometimes accused of nimi not in my
backyard motivation we may be called
activists in a dismissive way or
Outsiders trying to influence a
corporate development proposal in fact
we're stewards and caretakers people who
rise up to test to what is valuable
people who know what is endangered
because they live in an area use a
service or have recognized an injustice
it is a sacred Duty for stewards to
speak up the parks were set aside with
intention by stewards who came before us
they are preserved for their exceptional
value to our well-being and communities
for their plants and animals their clean
water air and Landscapes landfills and
their attendant insults to these very
values belong nowhere near Parks during
the pandemic numbers are staggering when
we look at the uptick of Youth in Parks
trails and other outdoor sanctuaries
that is clear testimony that we need
this bill to avoid the abomination of a
landfill near any number of our Parks
pars throughout the state are subject to
this sort of development and
encroachment how can compare with what
is lost yes can I interrupt please
you're well over three and a half
minutes can you wrap up
I will finish up yeah so we all know
that healthy parks and a healthy
environment mean tourism and a healthy
economy as commissioner Caswell said
just yesterday so I ask you on the
committee to step into stewardship here
join the volunteers who scrub the pit
toilets at my local park and the people
who saved frankone Notch Parkway when
people wanted to put an interstate
through the heart of the park um we all
have a role to play here so please take
this opportunity
and uh join the lineage that we have of
proud stewards in the state thank you
thank you Mr Set uh will you take
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Miss duet for your your your valuable
time um we've heard in previous
testimony that the existing regulatory
framework is perfectly capable of
dealing with any sighting issues when it
comes to landfills do you believe that
the state has the right to impose new
regulatory Frameworks based on new
opinion I do believe that I think we're
in a situation that we haven't come to
before I'm not satisfied that there has
been an adequate site review um you know
laws change all the time because the
laws and regulations in place are not
adequate and I I would seems to me this
is an example of that situation we're
seeing something here that would be
devastating and I would say not only to
this little Park somehow the
conversation has devolved to just
focusing on this park but this whole
region is going to be terribly impacted
it's known as the backyard you know the
vacation land of New Hampshire and this
is everybody's backyard so I think this
is a a problem we haven't seen before
and it's perfectly justifiable and
essential that we stand up and address
Justice for the threat that it is to the
whole
questions right seeing none uh thank you
for your
testimony next we will
call Steve changaris from the
office
are
go uh good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee thanks for the
opportunity to testify my name is Steve
changaris I am uh a 30-year veteran of
the national waste and recycling
Association I've sort of dedicated my
life to everything about waste and
recycling in the Northeast part of the
country here including New Hampshire
thank you very much for having this
hearing it's a great discussion um we
submitted some testimony online earlier
so comments stand and what I'll do is
just touch a couple of key points
because I know you're pressed for time
you know one um our industry is entirely
dedicated to the hierarchy waste
reduction recycling Organics management
construction and demolition processing
and other waste diversion programs
and and and and that's where we're
really putting a lot of the industry's
best efforts forward they're essential
to the US EPA and the de's Environmental
Management policies for Waste we're
doing that but as we do that we also
have to have the disposal part of the
equation accounted for so uh we often
think that um this is a very difficult
area site development is is incredibly
extraordinarily difficult um and that's
why we're having this hearing today but
as much as we're doing all these other
things like bringing recycling
facilities online and processing CN D
debris this is my industry as a
collective because I represent uh all
the wasted recycling companies the
collectors the Facility Owners and the
like uh we manage this material and we
try to do it with the higher and best
use in mind uh and we do do it with the
higher and best use in mind so uh
disposal is an element that often gets
overlooked make makes very very hard
decisions um there's an ample discussion
today about change what I'm going to
just it's in the testimony but it's
about changing the rules in the middle
of the game um I'm not a lawyer I'm a
simple political scientist that's been
in this field for a long time and what
we've seen is this often happens um it's
very hard to site and build a facility
when you get halfway through the process
and the goal line moves or the
regulations change and you know we're
always anxious to have long discussions
about Solid Waste policy and coming up
with the best regulatory system to to
drive home those policies but what I'm
here to testify to is that New Hampshire
has an excellent Bedrock set of
regulations to manage modern uh US EPA
recous subtitle d uh and waste energy
disposal infrastructure it's been tested
it's been proven it's been tweaked it's
been um legislated and we think it's an
excellent system and the last point that
I'd like to to make um regarding the the
language in the bill um the private
sector is so involved in Solid Waste
Management everywhere in the country we
invest tens of millions hundreds of
millions of dollars in essential
environmental infrastructure from
recycling centers to landfills to
Organics management the whole nine yards
and it often is involved in a public
private partnership and if we're reading
this bill correctly you're essentially
uh taking what has worked well for New
Hampshire and has worked well for the
industry and the nation in a whole as a
whole and saying that there's going to
be no more private involvement in this
area that it's going to have to be done
on estate or a public land and that's
not typical to the way we manage Solid
Waste and Recycling issues in in the
nation and we're we we we want to take
the opposite frame saying the current
Way New Hampshire is structur it system
is really excellent It's attracted a lot
of private investment it's it's a
taxpaying business we employ people and
we're anxious to bring new
infrastructure to the state and raise it
to the next bar but we we have to look
at it in that full um um um rainbow of
all the different kinds of facilities
that we operate if you take the disposal
piece out uh it's going to be very
difficult for us to do the other things
we'd like to do thank you for your time
today folks the testimony is right and
if there's any questions I'll be glad to
ask any questions for Mr
shangar representative
B thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um I I heard you state that you you
interpreted part of the bill as saying
that there could be no more private
landfills built in in New Hampshire if
this becomes L can you kind of um expand
on that just a little bit you person uh
that I've heard say that and I've read
the bill and I don't think it says that
so um you just let us know kind of
what I believe it's in the uh there's
some um severe limitations if not an
outright prohibition on the development
of any privately develop landfill
capacity in the state language in the in
the me measure appears to sanction in
favor St the state only to allow
publicly cited and developed landfills
in the future and that's that exclusion
about uh state or or Municipal lands and
then obviously the prohibition on the
state park the two mile radius so um
again all those issues are currently
controlled for very well we believe in
the current citing assignments in the
state if a town or municipality or the
state itself wants to advance a project
it may if a private company uh uh or a
Consortium of companies wants to advance
a project it may but it they both each
have to meet very stringent criteria
that's under your statutes and
Regulatory uh enforcement system and and
and and citing
process thank you sir
follow you Mr chairman and thank you so
much for taking my followup um I
definitely see the part in the Bill
about the two mile uh boundary around
any state park I don't see anything that
says that um there would be any other
restriction on private landf have you
read the bill itself yes I have and the
copy that I read had it and um I I sorry
I can't access it right now because my
computer screen's tied up on the zoom
call but I'd be glad to it's the second
section of the bill I I believe it's in
the second
section all right any uh any additional
questions all right so thank you for
coming in today thank
you pull up Bill
Al
if you're out there could you put your
perhaps all
right come
Robert do you hear me we can I'll just
remind please drive the state of the
three minutes youve got several people
still to go behind you sure um my name
is Bob gillo uh I'm an employee of CMA
engineers in Portsmouth I'm a Maine
resident I'm a New Hampshire registered
professional engineer and have been
practicing Landfield Engineering in the
state for 36 years um I'm the
engineering project manager for the
cassella grand State Landfield project
in Dalton uh we're part of a team that
includes a wetland scientist a
hydrogeologist Tim White who you've met
um um the surveyor air compliance people
Yan Cassell's operations engineering
legal and compliance Staff All in an
effort to permit the grand estate
landfill site um in 2020 the team
submitted applications to the dees
Wetlands Bureau and to dot for a highway
access permit um a Dees Solid Waste
permit application will be submitted
later this week um and applications for
a Dees groundw a release detection
permit and an air emissions permit are
expected to be submitted later this year
we've been working since 2017 to fully
comply with all federal and state
landfill
regulations we did conduct a a Statewide
study to locate the most favorable
landfill site uh prospective sites were
evaluated for compliance with all of the
sighting rules that are intended to
protect groundwater surface water and uh
public health health and safety um in
the wetlands know Sam Nikolai went
through a lot of the criteria used uh in
sighting and I won't repeat that he
covered most of them um but if you want
more information on our our sighting
work um the wetlands permit application
report contains a a detailed section
that um uh describes the process used to
delect this to select the dton site so
if you're interested i' I'd go to that
resource uh so in closing um the
cassella project team is worked over the
past three years to comply with the
complex and thorough permitting process
that's already in place changing the
rules at this late date will have a
damaging effect on permitting much
needed future disposal capacity of New
Hampshire um and I don't I don't think
any public or private entity would
embark on this timec consuming and
expensive permitting process knowing
that at the end of the process a law
could be passed to deny them or permit
um also passing the proposed law
bypasses the established rulemaking
process that usually considers uh input
from all stakeholders um so that's my
testimony thank you thank you uh will
you take some questions sure rep
c yes thank you Mr chairman
uh um as far as I know the castella
office uh headquarters is in Vermont is
that correct yes the corporate
headquarters yes how many l how many
cassella landfills are there in Vermont
as compared to New
Hampshire yeah I don't practice in
Vermont but it's my understanding
there's
one there's one Vermont and how many are
there in New Hampshire uh there's
one there's there's one in North Country
there's one in Bethlehem right now the
North Country facility and the Dalton
facility would replace that when North
when the Bethlehem facility
closes
okay uh do you know do you know if
there's any difference in the speaking
of rulemaking is there a difference
between Vermont and New Hampshire when
it comes to Ru
making I'm not familiar with the Vermont
process okay thank you uh repres EXC
representative
dutson uh yes thank you for taking my
question um Mr gillo I think um Mr
Nikolai had talked about a process where
if uncontaminated water is comes into
the landfill and then it's uh monitored
and it's contaminated when it goes out
um if that's the case then then uh how
is that aerated what what do you do with
that contaminated water if that tends to
be the
case um well if you're speaking to
contaminated groundwater I would defer
to um Tim White who testified earlier
he's a hydrogeologist who will be in
charge of monitoring this facility and
and would be in charge of remediating
any any kind of release but I I would
like to emphasize the point that this
facility is going to have have a double
line system and that that system and the
materials used in the system and the
procedures used to build it have have
been in place for 35 years in in New
Hampshire and and it's been proven to
work I I I would reinforce what Sam said
I'm not aware of any landfill in New
Hampshire or in Northern New England um
that has leaked through its liner and
created an issue that was measurable um
much less created a problem so I think
there's a high confidence level in these
facilities that they they do not leak
and this one won't leave thank you thank
Mr thank you for coming in today T
thanks all right next I'll pull up
Jeremy
balof
R off if you're out could you put your
[Music]
C
hello hello hi this is Pam Kath um thank
you Mr chairman and committee members
for letting me speak against HB
177 um I'm probably one of of the
few lifelong family members in the town
of Dalton my family has lived here for
decades it used to be uh a quiet and
pleasant
town and it is a small town it's poor
made up mostly of elderly and low income
but Dalton has been targeted citizens
are being harassed sazed and intimidated
over the possibility of a landfill
coming to town some don't dare to speak
their minds for fear of consequences
suffered by the anti-land landfill
faction we've seen their violence and
intimidation firsthand the number of
Dalton residents who could benefit from
hosting a landfill are small compared to
the large number of non-residents who
are only too glad to declare they are
the majority and they know what is best
best for who not for Dalton this town
has become so divided since the Takeover
of the anti- landfill factions neighbors
you've known forever are not speaking to
each other why even our board has
members of the anti- landfill faction on
it how fair is that to the residents of
dalon defeated before we even start the
landfill would give Dalton a wonderful
tax base an opportunity to provide
services to our elderly an opportunity
to get our Police Department back
because we have a lot of drug activity
here grows and thrives here why because
Dalton is poor it attracts gets
attracted by poor towns having local law
enforcement in this town
again would Aid the already stretched
State Police but how do we do that by
hosting a landfill our EMS fire and
Highway departments could also benefit
by hosting a landfill while I have no
complaints on their services now they do
the best they can with what they have
but if funded by hosting a landfill they
could do so much more another benefit of
landfill hosting would be the
opportunity to create high quality
internet service this would provide all
of the rural spots in our towns internet
service for those who work online school
online attend public meetings online or
those that just enjoy being
online we could also become educated
firsthand on Recycling and repurposing
that is what we want right I've been to
the cassella proposed site and I think
it's going to be great and I've also
been to the Bethlehem site and it
doesn't smell it's not dirty a lot of
those people that are opposing the
landfill have not even been there to
find out for
themselves so for the good of the future
we should defeat HB
177 I'm angered at the elite few in
Dalton that accuse us of not wanting to
pay our taxes and that is the reason we
want a landfill we want to pay our taxes
but we have a hard time paying them they
don't have that problem they are out of
touch with the real Dalton Lifestyle the
school and County taxes are going up I
wonder how the luck board will handle
that in a poor town with no money raise
our taxes so in closing I say don't
banish the landfills they're the ones
trying to take care of the trash that
everyone generates they are the ones
developing new ways to recycle and
repurpose the trash it's their job
turning trash into treasure as one might
say the anti- landfill group should be
going after the packaging developers and
product manufacturers then there would
be less of a need for landfills
landfills provide a solution to today's
throwaway society and that Society will
not be changing anytime soon and as far
as Forest Lake being pristine the Forest
Lake members know it is not what about
the boat gasoline and oil issues and
other issues that plague that WRA up
your your nearly four minutes so sorry
thank you so much would you take some
questions
sure
B thank you Miss Kath for taking my
question um I'm just looking for
clarification on one thing I thought I
heard you say there was violence or
something you
acts thank you for taking my followup
Could you um expand a little bit on the
violent
Acts when we were having our town
meeting um for the uh zoning uh people
were being harassed and vehicles shaken
landfill great thank you any other
questions
representa thank you Mr chair and thank
you cther for taking my question
question I'm interested to know um you
have an idea how much
um income your town would benefit from
with this
landfill uh coming to your
town would it be in terms of increased
tax money uh to the facility
or you know other other means of can you
elaborate on that sure Canen thank you
um yes it would be inre
tax money make us a nice tax space we
could get services in the town that are
may never have been there um we have a
lot of seniors living there I'm not so
sure we have any services for them our
EMS and Highway Department and fire
department like I said they do great
with what they have but they could do a
whole lot more with extra funding um I
don't see this as a loss if anything I
think that for Lake would be uh much
better handled with extra financing um
sorry extra funding um to create a
committee to take care of that Lake and
make sure it does not get Pro
polluted thank you any additional
questions from the
board not seeing any we than you for
coming in speak thank
you all right next up we have Nancy
Morrison
hello can you hear me hi Nancy we can
please try and keep within three minutes
thank you um I'm Nancy Morrison from
Mont Vernon New
Hampshire uh good day to Chairman Pearl
and the committee members and thank you
I'd like to momentarily digress from my
prepared
notes to address the gentleman who
earlier said that incineration and
landfills are the only major way to deal
with waste he failed to mention specific
reuse methods and if New Hampshire
chooses to take care of its own Solid
Waste
responsibilities composting organic
waste or kitchen waste would remove a
quarter to a third of what now goes into
land fills and could be done at
municipal waste sites and sold back or
donated to the public where there is a
will there is a way but now back to
state parks which is what we really are
talking about here today permit me to
ask you if you live any of you near one
of the 68 affordable and beautiful state
parks in New Hampshire do you recreate
in these spaces have you worked or
volunteered in any of these New
Hampshire state parks have your friends
and relatives enjoyed their time there
and have you noticed visitors from other
parts of the world who are delighted to
vacation in and at our Lakes waterways
campgrounds and trails I have the
benefit due to the foresight of those
before us to say yes to all these
questions and I imagine you are nodding
your heads too upon my
asking I also drive by a corporate
landfill weekly my windows are rolled up
L I become literally sickened by the
buffed noxious rotten egg like odor that
routinely emanates from the mountain of
partially outof State trash is
paradoxically called a
landfill if seagulls are not circling it
is apt to be because disruptive noise
cannons have been fired to Ward them off
their return is predictable and certain
we know that land dwelling seagulls
pollute our lakes ponds and waterways
with a constant deposit of high nitrogen
feces that also carry fungal and back
bacterial diseases I'm reminded also
that the EPA says that all landfills
leak eventually
period And by the way that landfill I
drive by is considered air quotes
state-of-the-art So I ask you one more
question before I leave you today do we
proactively commit to stopping the
threat of a new landfill being located
closer than two miles from one of our
New Hampshire state parks or do we leave
this in congruity to our descendants
left with a preventable mess never again
to regain what is
lost I hope you will decide that a two
mile buffer zone between a new landfill
and a New Hampshire State Park makes
sense in relation to science economics
quality of life and protection of our
unique and precious natural
resources I urge you to pass HB
177 and I thank you for your time and
thoughtful
consideration thank thank you any
the look like you get off easy thank you
for coming in today thank
you all right Kevin
[Music]
Wham there's more sense in that than
said
unmuted now how do I get on you're on we
can hear you okay all right I'll try to
be brief I know there's a whole lot
going on today uh but first and most of
anything I I'm opposed to Bill
177 because again you're changing the
rules at the end of the game I think it
should be up to the Dalton to reserve
the rights to weigh the pros and cons of
the educated themselves on a large
industrial project in their town that
could be a huge benefit to
them there's many Dal folk in business
who will not speak out on this bill
because of uh some attacks
verbally uh
from uh the Forest Lake
group uh cuz we we're we're sinister
people because we'd like to make the
choice ourselves anyways uh I'm not
afraid to speak out for these people you
know there is a lot of taxpayers in the
town of Dalton that are retired and
don't have a big retirement fund and
have to go without things and change
their lifestyle so they can pay their
taxes that's why I feel this is a good
opportunity for the taxpayers to make a
decision and not the state halfway
through the
game so uh there's many many other
things I'd like to say but I know you're
trying to keep this brief and I would
like to let some of the other taxpayers
weigh in on this so uh again Kevin
Woodham senior taxpayer and dalon lived
here my whole life thank you very much
you Lori
Boswell
[Music]
yes can you hear me now can miss Boswell
please
keep I I will be brief my name is lri
Boswell and I want to thank you for this
opportunity to speak in support of hb1
177 I'm a native of New Hampshire born
in and raised in Littleton and now
living in
Franconia I have traveled extensively
throughout the United States and the
world but more importantly I have also
visited each of the 234 towns in New
Hampshire and the two dozen
unincorporated places I can say from
this firsthand experience that we have
an incredibly beautiful state rich in
natural resources from the great North
Woods down to the madok region and over
to the Sea Coast I'm the youngest of
four children some of my Fondest
Memories as a child include going for a
weekend drive through Franconia or
Crawford Notch state parks climbing the
lookout tower at week State Park
exploring Odon State Park and taking
swim lessons at Forest Lake State Park
New Hampshire is blessed with an
abundance of state parks forests
mountains and historic sites that
attract local families and tourists
alike the impact of our natural
resources on the local and state economy
and on the quality of life are
substantial I have to ask then why would
anyone think it would be a good idea to
allow a landfill to be established
within close proximity of a state park
the potential adverse impact on present
and future use of the park and the
surrounding area is clear I would name
the following concerns as only my start
surfacing groundwater contamination
noise pollution from landfill operation
and from Trucking air pollution
including the unpleasant odors and pest
animals I do recognize the need to
address Solid Waste Management and
recycling as consumers as municipalities
and as a state the solution however must
protect New Hampshire's natural
resources and our quality of life I urge
the committee to pass this legislation
to protect all New Hampshire state parks
thank you for your
Boswell all right not seeing any thank
you thank
bannett Thomas if you're on could you
put your hand up we're not finding you
right
Brian Tom if you're on could you put
up
Sebastian
me Sebastian are you able to hear me
yeah I can hear you right go ahead sir
you have three
minutes uh good afternoon chairman thank
you very much members of the Comm
uh my name is Sebastian Fuentes uh I'm
an active member of the North Country
Community uh I'm just here to ask you
for um to your support for this bill 177
for a few reasons one of them because
it's the right thing to do to protect
our valuable natural natural resources
here in New
Hampshire I will say I was a little
discouraged by uh Mr Nikolai earlier
from Cella saying that you know uh we
won't be able to see anything in two and
a half decades well I'm here I'm here
testifying F not because of for myself
for my own benefit but for the benefit
of my kids and the grandkids that in two
and a half decades they be able to enjoy
that Forest Lake Park without any
issues uh Mr Swan earlier from safe
Forest Lake mentioned also that this
bill will dictate whether or not any
other state park in the near future will
suffer from the same piece of
legislation and I think that's really
important at the same time I'm a
Hospitality manager up here in the North
country one of those grand hotels and I
can tell you that building a landfill
will be extremely detrimental to the
tourism industry here in
Hampshire imagine for example this
property like uh the mountain bu Grand
where you're sitting on the balcony
spending $400 or $500 a night and you're
enjoying the beautiful presidential
range in Mount Lafayette and then over
the West Corner you'll see a
landfill what's going to do that to the
tourism industry to local restaurants to
souvenir shops to local shops in the
area uh I don't I think putting a
Landfield Hill will be really really the
wrong thing to
do uh at the same time I do a lot of
conferences a lot of catering events a
lot of uh Gatherings uh obviously we due
to co those those are kind of slow right
now but in the past every time they ask
me uh where can we go to you know to
find some outdoor recreation and always
Forest Lake in the presidential range is
one of those spots where I will send
people to
go Forest Lake is a place where my son
learned how to swim my daughter learned
how to
fish I want to invite every single one
of you members of the this community to
please visit the North Country I think
uh representative from Nash sopie K is
she came here last year uh and was
gracious enough to walk around the pro
the park and see it but I would love to
invite each one of you guys to come up
here and and see what we have in here
see how beautiful is to have a a weekend
with your family sitting at the park
enjoying the the Water kaying Swimming
fishing without being disrupted without
any odors without any truck noises is
the safe spot for many people lowincome
middle class and higher income people to
go gather and enjoy the
nature I hope you guys Rec consider the
support for Bill
177 and hopefully I'll see you guys up
here in the North Country soon thank you
very
much thank you any questions for Mr
fantes yes representative B thank thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr FES for
taking my question um I'm very
appreciative that you mentioned the
prior testimony of of Mr Nikolai when he
stated that the height of the landfill
um is such that it will not be
seen for I think he said 24 years I'm
curious since you've been to Forest Lake
State Park um do you think it's likely
that you would see swarms of Seagulls
flying above the the site of the the
metric I do think so I think that's
possible I'm not a uh engineer a
forestry management person like I said
I'm a Hospitality manager but I can I
can see that I go kayaking all the time
and you can see Mountains for Miles if
you're on the lake so I think that's
that's a possibility uh I don't know the
technicalities of it but I I'm pretty
sure that that's possible
T all right not seeing any thank you sir
for coming in thank you minute Mr I'm
C yeah sorry thanks for taking myh
question Mr chair and uh thank you Mr
Fuentes uh I appreciate your your
um your uh point of view as a
Hospitality manager and someone involved
in that industry in the North Country I
was wondering if you could just uh give
me your opinion on we've heard some
testimony from residents of Dalton uh
who are talking about the benefits that
would come to certain you know certain
benefits that would come to the town
from the sighting of the landfill uh
because of Dalton's you know low income
status um do you think that perhaps you
know it benefits private companies to
seek out uh seek out towns and regions
where people are needy in that way in
that way when they when they come to try
to seek permits to get site sites for
landfills like that you think that's an
advantage represent we we lost Mr
Morrison
can you hear me okay you can so you have
three minutes go ahead thank you I'll
try and do it in
two um there's been a lot said this
afternoon um I I clearly uh would uh
strongly encourage you to approve House
Bill
177 uh I would remind everybody that
house bill 177 is not a ban on landfills
it's really a protection for one of our
most precious assets which is our state
parks and their surrounding areas I
think this is a very common sense
approach to what is having listen to
this for the last three hours um it
seems like a very complicated uh subject
matter but the more I think about it I
also think that this is basically common
sense I would ask the committee to think
about does it make any sense at all to
you to
situate a very large uh landfill very
close within hundreds of yards of a
state par park or a body of water that
is used by the public in great numbers
it seems to me that makes no sense at
all and there's got to be a better
solution I would also remind everybody
that this legislation actually started
before any permitting process started
it's come up several times that um you
know we're changing the rules of the
game that's not necessarily true the
legislation for this bill its
predecessor was passed through the house
and if it wasn't for the covid-19
pandemic um this all would have happened
long before any permanent process had
started I think this is very smart
legislation I think it's uh it's
something that's very needed and I think
if you talk to
Dees their their set of rules there's a
there's a there's no question there's an
exhaustive set of rules for getting a
permit but that's a dynamic situation
that's that's subject to change and I
think as a legislative body it's one of
the previous speakers asked you to be uh
caretakers of the land and to be and now
is the time to step up so I would
encourage you to do that any any
permitting process that would allow um a
large landfill to be placed this close
to a state park or this close to Forest
Lake makes no sense at all to me and
whatever the science is and whatever
Goodwill and positive intent uh cassella
or any other of the landfill developers
have um their their best laid plans if
something go South there's there there
is no remedy for it and it just doesn't
make sense to put th those precious
resources at risk I would encourage you
to please pass House Bill 177 thank
Marson all right not seeing any thank
you
sir next we'll bring up fredd Anderson
so we have three more uh three more
people to testify for the committee I'll
just remind the last three of you if
you're going to repeat something that
someone else has said before just let's
try and keep it brief min's been sitting
here for nearly three hours and we still
have work to do after this so I'd like
to wrap up fairly quickly if we could
not that I want to limit anyone speech
but let let's try and stick to new
points and just touch on the highlights
Anderson
can you hear me I can Mr Anderson go
ahead you have three minutes my name is
Fred Anderson uh I have lived on Forest
Lake off and on since 1977 when we
bought a camp here we built a retirement
home here 14 years ago I would have
never done that had I any notion of a
landfill being put what will be within
probably a half mile of my front yard uh
but I'm here to talk to you you've heard
lots of things by the way I'm also
president of the Forest Lake Association
you've heard from a lot of my fellow
friends on this Lake about what this
means about prevailing RNs you've heard
about people that have grown up here all
their life we've raised our kids here I
want to talk to you about three things I
want to talk to you about the
environment I want to talk to you about
the ecology and I want to talk to you
about the economy I'm really just stress
that is Cella has talked about all of
this with all their fancy monitoring
Wells and whatever they keep slipping by
the possibility of these other things I
want to talk about what happens when the
stuff that goes into the ground by the
way it's going to be there a lot longer
than 35 years it's going to be there a
lot longer than I'm going to be here I
dare say it's going to be there a lot
longer of any of you we're being called
upon here to be stewards of this gift to
us but there's this thing called
atmospheric
deposition that stuff you throw dirt on
top of it but it continues to decompose
and release gases it releases methane it
releases carbon dioxide two of the most
critical chemicals in terms of of global
warming and in terms of carbon
footprints for Earth rain if that
landfill goes in here this Lake will be
dead Within 30 to 50 years I guarantee
you why because they can't control the
leeching of that yes we know what those
candy cane white PVC car things look
like all over these and of course but
the ground is releasing this gas and
this gas then when the water hits it
turns it into acid rain and then we're
talking about posos that's also being
generated and blown into the air and yes
the prevailing winds come from the the
north down across the South I live in
the south end on the west side of the
lake I can tell you exactly what the
prevailing winds are they're not what
cassella tells you are and they don't
change that often two I want to talk
about the ecology what's the difference
between ecology and environment it's the
way the environment decomposition
problems interact with the biosphere the
biosphere has to do not only with
Wildlife not only with fish not only
with game but with you and me and we're
talking about cancer we're talking about
a whole series of other problems not the
least of which would happen and of
course the whole issue of water leeching
into the landfill you've heard that the
EPA says these things leak sooner or
later they leak a 100 to 200 years is
what we're talking about here possibly
longer I don't think we have anyone in
the industry who can tell us what will
be happening in 100 to 200 years no how
no matter how scientific they're trying
to be the last issue is economic you've
heard it I don't need to repeat it you
know how dependent the state is on
tourism dollars and Recreation dollars I
feel a little passionate I think you can
hear it let me be clear I live within
less than a while of where this place is
envisioned to go it's
180 acres and that's the same size of
the lake and then there will be all the
applications later for wanting to EXP B
it talk to the people in Bethlehem about
what life has been like with this group
of people ladies and gentlemen thank you
for your time thank you for your work
and thank you for caring for the people
and the resources of the State of New
Hampshire is there any questions from Mr
Anderson
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Anderson for your testimony
and for taking my question um I I've
heard it a few times now A lot of people
seem to live out their retirement years
up there in in in dalon by the lake and
uh another thing I know is that a lot of
people uh for a lot of people a
significant portion of their life
savings uh is is in their home uh what
do you think will happen to property
value forth Lake if a landfill is placed
nearby oh they'll drop
dramatically and the concern about
property up here will suddenly cease to
be who's going to want to come up here
and build a house next to a landfill yes
I retired up here we came up here for
almost 40 years before I retired I'm a
presbyterian Minister we were up here a
week to two weeks to three weeks in the
summer finally for the whole summer I
would have never invested the money I
invested in this house had I known there
was going to be a landfill next to it
and I'm not a wealthy man I'm not an
elite I'm not the kinds of folks the
folks by the way were testifying to and
by the way I was at that meeting in
Dalton and there was no violence I was
holding one of the signs urging the
people of Dalton to vote for zoning so I
think that's being misrepresented thank
you for your question thank you Mr any
other questions for Mr
hon right seeing none thank you sir we
appreciate your testimony thank you so
much all right is Adam
F yes can you hear me you can that quick
thank thank you uh Dr Adam finl I'm a a
Dalton resident voter uh professor of
environmental health science at
University of Michigan remotely of
course formerly taught at Princeton Penn
and Harvard uh I'm not anti- landfill I
think New Hampshire might well need one
or more landfills somewhere in the state
over the next 30 to 50 years but the
difference to Public Health and the
economy from a sensibly cited landfill
and a poorly cited one is enormous there
are millions of Acres available land in
our state uh and all this fill does of
course is to say that a very tiny
percentage of that land among the most
vulnerable and valuable portions of it
should be off limits to new commercial
construction Mr changaris is just wrong
it's a one paragraph bill that does not
say anything about uh Banning private
landfills it bans it in 79 two M circles
around our state parks I want to make
one quick point about economics I
actually helped invent some of the
methods used to do cost benefit analysis
in the 1980s this bill has zero cost and
it won't kill a single job many states
and towns forbid liquor stores from
being built next to churches or schools
no one have the go to claim that's a job
killing restriction the total number of
liquor stores won't change if a tiny
percentage of all possible places are
denied to them uh when you guys debated
this bill uh last year I heard criticism
that two miles is arbitrary with all due
respect this doesn't make sense to me if
I could offer an analogy it's like
saying what speed limit should we have
in front of a grammar school in a case
where the current law allows drivers to
speed past the school at 75 miles an
hour there's no magic number for what a
lower limit should be but surely
legislators can choose a better number
than 75 miles per hour so what's the
current code the dees code says you can
put a landfill 200 feet uh from a
permanent water body so all this bill
does is increase that arbitrary setback
by a factor of about 50 fold is that too
protective not protective enough give me
one minute and I'll try and explain it
when considering the inevitable leaks
from a landfill it's it might be helpful
to think not in terms of units of
distance but units of time how much time
might it take for contaminated
groundwater to move 200 ft so here's an
accurate quote quote depending on
various factors it can take weeks months
or even years for groundwater to move as
little as 100 feet end quote I found
that quote in a legal brief written by
cassella in defense of A Clean Water Act
complaint made against it so that's
their quote so at let's let's forget
about weeks let's be generous and use
months two months for 100 feet is of
course 50 feet a month so at 50 ft per
month 200t provides the state only four
months to detect and avert contamination
this is obviously unreasonable but with
a two mile buffer you might have 18
years to find and fix this may not be
enough time to detect the problem and
with great expense intercept the plume
of groundwater and block it from
reaching the surface water but at least
18 years gives you a fighting chance so
the choice between let's quote four
months and quote 18 years is exactly the
kind of choice that you were elected to
make and I submit that uh increasing
that temporal setback uh is a I won't
call it a no-brainer but it's it's
Common Sense let me make two more very
quick points about setbacks and I'll
stop uh no one's brought this up yet
today for 20 years there's been a
federal law prohibiting new landfill
construction public or private within
six miles of a general aviation airport
this is about concern of course about
pressible waste and seagulls I've
actually studied the risks of bird
strikes at airports they're very
uncommon I looked at the faa's database
today there have been no bird strikes in
New Hampshire ever that have caused
injury to human beings but nevertheless
we protect airports to a six mile uh
radius and right now Landfield rivers
and streams and lakes only to 200 feet
it actually turns out in Dalton if
cassella wanted to locate 2011 feet from
the West Shore of Forest Lake they
couldn't do that not thanks to Dees but
because the Whitefield region airport is
just six miles and and little under six
miles from the from the closest from the
furthest point of the shore one more qu
point and I'll stop uh I put in my
written testimony and as attachment a
recent study from Duke University
talking about a seagull waste and the
phosphorus and nitrogen they add to Lake
water someone mentioned uh Forest Lake
had its first recorded ever harmful
algal bloom last summer after a quick
sudden rainstorm washed some soil into
the lake so I strongly suspect that that
even a two-mile setback will be
insufficient to prevent seagulls from
being attracted to the water bodies and
a harmful algal bloom as you may know
it's not only dangerous to humans and
potentially deadly to household pets but
it's an early stage in the process of
urif foration if allowed to continue
that will not inaccurately be called a
dead lake so thank you for the chance to
explain why this bill is a cost benefit
choice that has substantial public
benefits zero public costs and no
private cost whatsoever that can't be
erased merely by developers choosing
from among the vast number of sensible
alternative sites thank you for your
time thank you Mr frer will you take
some questions from the board of course
sure representative
Bixby yes uh thank you uh Mr chair thank
you uh Mr fle for taking my question um
so you mentioned the issue of cost
benefit analysis and one of the benefits
that was cited of the landfill was that
it would provide an increased inre in
tax base and tax income to this town of
Dalton uh one of the uh downside U costs
that was cited by other um uh testifiers
was that uh it would have a damaging
effect on the tourism economy around in
that in the um Dalton White Field area
uh do you have a sense of how these
compare well any sense that I would have
would be impressionistic I think they're
both large potential sums I think the
experience in Bethlehem has been that
the promises of of money have not been
borne out but I'm trying to make a
somewhat different point this is a state
bill and we are focused on one project
but all I'm trying to say here is that
whatever uh economic harms and goods
come from a proposed landfill in Dalton
just by putting this two mile barrier
around state parks that cost and benefit
will just occur someplace else from a
state point of view this is a zero some
uh non-impact again this is about 1 to
2% of the land area of the state these
companies can locate in the other 98%
with with no problem at all it's just
parks and landfills lakes and landfills
you thank you Senator
B uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
Mr finle for taking my question um I
believe you're a professor of
Environmental Health Sciences and I'm so
glad that you are because I think make
it very appropriate for ask this
question um presented from Cella earlier
quite a while ago Mr uh Fusco
recommended that we defer to
Representatives um of Pella as a source
of scientific information um my daughter
is in high school and sometimes I help
her with her clients homework one of the
things I've learned very recently is
that sources of scientific information
should not be trusted unless they are
from an unbiased Source would you say
that Cassel systems is an unbiased
source of scientific information in this
case wow that's you know that's a tough
question because uh first of all I've
written articles about this I actually
am not that concerned about financial
bias I tend to look more at whether
people are right or wrong whether
they're credential or not whether they
know what they're talking about or not
and it's a tough question for me because
I've been sued by Cassell already for
defamation uh simply for having been an
association with a similar name to
another Association we were dismissed
from that suit and I have no qualms at
all about talking at a legislative
hearing uh all I will say is I have
seen profoundly unscientific amateurish
statements from this company already and
I have been LED knowing nothing about
them two years ago to mistrust them in
the future uh the the idea that
groundwater can't flow up Hill uh that's
Voodoo science um it it can flow uphill
in fractured granite and I remind you
that I have moved now to the Granite
State and we're talking about the
granite state landfill so yes you need a
good source of not only unbiased but uh
credential and expert scientific
information I'm happy to uh either on my
own or through my colleagues to try try
that thank you uh representative
verville thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr fingle for uh taking my question so
we keep coming back to uh to sort of a
similar point so I I'll ask you for your
your opinion on the matter you say that
landfills and parks and landfills and
open bodies of water uh don't mix and
that that's common sense so it's a
two-part question do you believe that
the bill should be amended to disallow
landfills within 2 feet of open
groundwater and if the bill was amended
to say that um what percentage of land
in New Hampshire do you think would
remain available for potential landfill
development well I will definitely take
a look at a map and try because I heard
your question earlier today it's a good
question how much of the state would be
off limits if it was 2 miles from you
said 2 feet I assume you mean two miles
from any any permanent water B
um all I'll say is I think state parks I
looked at the Wikipedia page at all the
pictures I've been to probably 15 or 20
of these but I would say two-thirds of
the state parks either have water body
in their name or obvious from the
picture there's a water body nearby and
I assume that these particular water
bodies were chosen for tourist value for
ecological value for historic value so
I'm not sure it should be amended to
include every body waterer in the state
I guess my bottom line would be uh maybe
this is now self-interest because of
where I live but I'd like you to pass
this bill now and then consider amending
it to expand the the buffers in the
future thank you Mr ble thank you Mr
chairman sure thank
spe uh no question I forgot to take my
hand down
testimony thank
[Music]
Hayes ell if you could put your hand up
on the account you want us to pull up it
unmute can you hear me I'm sorry that's
okay I've got you now all right
okay um it looks like I'm batting Queen
up and I will um have mercy on you I
just want to make a several comments um
the most frequent question I get when I
tell people about the Forest Lake
campaign is why next to a lake and a
state park why not somewhere else and
the only real answer we ever got from
the developers is that they found in
quotes a willing
landowner someone who happened to own
Dalton land directly abing the state
park and was willing to sell it to them
the fact that it's a terrible place in
my opinion for a landfill has not
stopped them and when the permit for the
Dalton landfill is as we hope denied by
Dees it's very likely the landfill
developer is going to be looking for
other willing land owners elsewhere in
New Hampshire and as we all know there
are vast tracks of privately owned land
throughout New England as well as in New
Hampshire land that could easily host a
for profit
landfill and there's undoubtedly many
more willing land
owners and to bring HB 177 back to
something that provides Statewide
benefits for all of us HB 177 will
ensure that wherever New Hampshire's
next for-profit landfill is permitted
it will be at least two miles away from
the state parks inner near your
District um I want to respond quickly to
the notion that we are trying to change
the rules in
Midstream uh we as you probably know
started this last year before any
permits were ever uh submitted and we
hope that you will consider that oneyear
delay due to covid when you think about
the notion of us trying to change in
Midstream um while we were silenced by
covid and while things were stalled with
the state legislature Cella of course
went full stream ahead with all the work
they needed to do so there is a mismatch
now and uh please do think about the
fact that we tried to start this last
year and that's about all I want to say
except to remind you that each of you is
only one willing landowner away from
having this come to your state park and
I hope you'll keep that in mind and I
hope that you will decide
to uh make HB 177 ought to pass thank
you for your
time thank you very much for your
testimony is there any questions
representative po thank you Mr chairman
and thank you uh M cas for taking my
question
um by mentioning the whole um changing
the rules Midstream concept you kind of
um Peak my my memory or
my if there was a policy or a
constitutional provision or something
that would prevent legislation from
being passed if it affects current
activities do you think that we probably
legislation
I I do not recall Mr Balden what you're
specific um yeah um so I believe many
members uh who were opposed to the bill
stated that um we were we were changing
the rules uh during the the game um and
I guess I was just wondering if you
thought if there had been some kind of
policy in the legislature that we could
not pass any bills um that would affect
a current activity we would probably not
pass very much legislation would you um
I concur with that and I would also like
to say that some of the opposition on
the house floor last year was because at
that point we probably were a little too
ambitious we included the appalation
trail and that caused problems for Mount
Carberry as you know we all feel that
municipally owned uh waste districts
should in my opinion at least be the
future of solid waste disposal in New
Hampshire and not for profits and we
this year have been very careful to make
sure that um nothing in this very simple
nonpartisan bill will affect the
operations of Mount carbury including
expansions thank you any further
questions
seeing none I thank you so that's all I
have my open it up and is there anyone
else that would like to testify on this
before I close the hearing all right so
up see the hands up holy there tons
hi yes uh sorry about that I'm pretty
sure I signed up maybe there's a glitch
in the system as we're all dealing with
new stuff today uh my name is David
Creer I am director of public policy for
the business and industry Association of
New Hampshire uh we oppose this bill uh
for the simple reason that it follows
basic economics um as this bill if it
were to pass it would decrease capacity
and then as you decrease capacity uh you
know the uh the need uh or the supply
will go down and then the need um or the
demand for solid waste disposal will not
decrease uh anytime soon for sure um and
therefore the costs of solid waste
disposal will increase as we need to
find alternate sites or uh transport out
of state uh more waste than we currently
do uh and so this will result in
increased costs for businesses uh in the
state um and with that I'm happy to
conclude my testimony to save everyone
some time uh and answer any questions if
there are any thank you sir any uh
career not seeing any thank you for
testifying today I'm sorry actually I
believe uh representative s Kus was
trying to raise her
hand oh my apologies represent s Kus did
you have a question yes thank you uh Mr
chairman and thank you uh Mr Creer for
taking my question this is the end of
the day and the first time we've talked
about sending our garbage elsewhere and
I was wondering how much of our garbage
do we send out it seems like we're
taking in
more that is an excellent question and
unfortunately I don't have any answer
I'm sorry to disappoint you but I will
uh make a note to try and find out how
much it is um we definitely do not um
keep all of the waste we produce we do
export some but I'm not sure what the
ratio is so I will look that up and I
will get back to you thank you all right
career all right not seeing any thank
look like we have several more hands up
I'm going to give this hearing about
nine more minutes and at 4:30 I have to
close it because the committee has some
business that needs to get done today so
I'm going to ask any call on and let if
you're going to repeat something we've
heard I'm going to immediately stop you
and uh if not I'm going to give you
about 30 seconds to make your point
because I got to get through this and
Jones
all right thanks so much for having me
y'all let me condense my testimony into
30 seconds my name is Haley Jones she
they pronouns on abanaki land up here in
Vermont and I'm the Vermont and New
Hampshire Community organizer with
Community Action Works uh we work side
by side with everyday folks to pre to
prevent pollution and Seed Solutions
we've worked with folks in the North
Country for years and years and that's
why we're here today uh simply put we're
here in support of
hb77 uh we know that landfills
regardless of protection will eventually
leak so water pollution uh they can
spread noxious odors up to five miles
and we just don't think it's a good idea
to site them anywhere near uh New
Hampshire state parks and then finally
at the root of this this is a discussion
about how much waste you're producing
and what we're doing with that waste we
need to get at the root of the issue
which is that we're producing too much
waste instead of uh pushing more
landfills onto Rural and workingclass
towns in the North Country so asking you
again to support HB 177 and I will
submit my full and beautiful written
test Tony to all later thanks so much
thank you I appreciate
you all right next up is Nina
web actually Nina you've already
testified before the committee today I'm
going to uh I'm gonna actually Skip and
money is it okay to
go and Nina you've already testified
before the committee today we are really
short on time I'm going to I'm going to
ask you to submit any further comments
by
email
[Music]
then
thank you very much chairman and I
appreciate this time I am in support of
177 because I am a uh one that uses the
um beautiful area of uh that mount
mountain view grand Summit that Mr
Fuentes spoke about and I can't imagine
uh my my conference being scheduled
there we've been going there for a few
years now and uh with a landfill there I
I can't imagine us wanting to go back
there um I'm part of the nesw and that's
a very large conference for that
facility also there's an environmental
justice issue and um here we are again
with um a community that needs so many
services and supports um in their tax
base and a large corporation is coming
into their community and um using that
uh Community as a place to settle in and
use the the beautiful area as a a dump
and also um I'm very curious there was a
question asked about garbage into New
Hampshire and cella's off KY I'm gonna
have to cut you off I'm sorry you over a
minute now and and I just don't have
I've got a few others and I've only got
apologies yes sure go ahead thank you Mr
chair for taking my question and thank
you m
McKenzie you mention that you you do you
host a conference I um and if so can you
talk about the number of attendees and
how long do they stay when you have
those
conferences yes um so the nesw
conference is our annual conference that
includes uh Vermont uh Maine and New
Hampshire social workers and um I can't
really tell you I think about
250 something like that um attend the
conference so uh that's quite
um a large conference for that
facility thank
you and how long is your weekend or just
one
day it's uh two and a half
m I'm going to take one more and then
we're going to be done and if anyone
else has any further comments I'm going
to have to ask you to submit them to the
committee by email because we have a
hard stop to be out of the room at 5:00
and we have bills that we have to get
through the exact today because of uh
time constraints so my apologies for
anyone who's not going to get on today I
I've done my best to get you all in uh
we're going to bring up John T Hill and
this is going to be the last person
committee
hello this is John Tut Hill John could
you please keep it to less than a minute
here like 30 seconds I certainly can uh
John Tut Hill from ACTH New Hampshire
Sullivan County uh former member of the
ENA committee um long ago I will submit
written testimony uh one thing listening
to over three and or about three and a
half hours of testimony today is that
we're dealing with very very large
issues here long term uh going both back
and forward it struck me today that uh
we're we're looking at at a situation
where the site evaluation committee
would probably be an appropriate venue
or frankly the Public Utilities
Commission we're now looking at an
industry that basically is an
unregulated
Monopoly um I think we really need to
step back it's critically important I
think simply to hit the pause button and
passing HB
177 would be an effective way of doing
that thank you very much thank you sir I
appreciate your testimony
all right read blue sheet we going to
close this hearing got
335 in support 33
opposed with that I will close testimony
of hearing for House Bill 177 and we're
going to take about a five minute break
to let everybody stand up stretch their
legs and we'll come back and do the
exact session on the final two bills
thank you Mr chair what what was the
count of the support uh Reg
thank
you
e
back going to exact
session Bill we're going to do is house
fill
438 to
representative
than
you we have a motion to retain house B
438 is there a
second rep Highland second that am um
the motion right thank
you all right so we have a motion and a
second to retain House Bill 38 I'm going
to remind everybody I need you back on
video for the voting as I turn it over
the oh is anybody want any discussion
retain I'm moving it fast is there any
38 I not see
any
it
yes repr Davis yes St
yes yes Kennedy
yes
all right next up and our final bill is
House Bill
532 and I will look to representative
Bixby for a
motion thank you Mr chair um I would
like to move ought to pass with
202-211
H
amendment represent we could you repeat
your motion of moving the amendment okay
I would like to move Amendment uh two
021 D
0211 on HB
532 I will
second and may I speak to my motion
recognized so uh just to um touch on the
key aspects of what the amendment does
uh first of all the most important thing
is that uh what the uh bill will do as
amended is will provide the Department's
need for an efficient mechanism for
dealing with health certificates to
track to track animal transfers for
licensing uh for licensing of pet
vendors uh the um main things that the
amendment does is it Narrows the bill to
deal only only with health certificates
it eliminates fees it Ren it renames the
health certificate to the official
certificate of transfer which was a
department request it modifies the
confidentiality section to allow
official local federal and state in
investigations of specifically of animal
health and pet vendor license
investigations uh it strengthens the
confidentiality provision to prevent
unauthorized access and use of the data
it adds a civil penalty uh the adds the
possibility of a civil suit if that's
violated it adds a full-time it position
to the Department of agriculture markets
and foods to
design uh and uh manage the design put
together and manage the
database it adds an appropriation for
the second year of the management costs
it converts uh it it corrects some
wording flaws in the bill and and the
existing law and it removes the payback
from to the dedicated funds uh because
the fee that would have paid them back
is
eliminated uh
a couple things uh that are still in the
uh that it remain leaves in the original
bill is a clarification for dealing with
a health certificate waiver which was a
request of the department specifically
of the vets and uh it pays for the um uh
design and deployment uh with excess
money from the IP and product LIC
funds and uh
if anyone wants a a little more detail
on that I can give it to them if not
then I would be happy to start
voting all right so I'll
one and in our conversation
representative piby and I had a
conversation with the commissioner of
doit the commissioner of agriculture in
the state vetenarian and we discussed a
lot of the changes that we were making
and many of these changes were at the he
of them and their agencies in order to
comply with the areas work on on one of
the things that's in this bill as
representative Bixby discussed is a
full-time it position and one of the
things that will occur with that
full-time it position and I'm trying to
remember represent excuse me
representative Bix correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe the department back
currently has 12th of one person's time
dedicated to support its
it uh needs and this full-time position
would not only support the it needs of
of the database but the other needs that
are within the department that are
currently not being met right and that
is cor the 12th is correct and the
commissioner of it said that that would
probably decrease because of uh new
demands on their
time all right any other discussion from
committee members uh yes I I uh Sher
Duty I just had one question um so if
they if we include the IT person um does
that take care care of the
commissioner's concerns about uh the
ongoing funding of the database because
I know that that was a concern of his
but I'm assuming that the ongoing
funding issue you know relates to having
an IT person so do you understand what
I'm saying uh I the the ongoing funding
is something that um has more to do with
uh how the money gets into the system uh
the um for initially that it person I
believe would be paid for out of the uh
funds Set uh uh that are being used to
establish it uh and
uh and having an IT person who really
knows what's going on and is working
with the Department should help them get
a cheaper contract than they might
otherwise get uh but in terms of the
funding uh into future um future terms
of legislature that will depend on the
um continuing
appropriation uh
which in most departments have their
staff funded by General funding
Appropriations for a lot of their works
so that I think that's that's something
that is reasonable to expect because
this is for work that is required of
them by the state which they currently
don't have the resources to to do and
and I'll add or to that representa is
what one of the advantages well I guess
maybe not an advantage one of the things
that was sought after in this bill by
removing the fees and going to an
appropriation general fund appropriation
is back in 2018 when uh the legislature
decided to make this mandate that the
department do this and make it part of
their job they didn't bother to fund and
didn't feel that it was fair to put the
cost of funding that onto the the animal
owners of New Hampshire and especially
the readers and those who are who are
seeking these Health certificates and it
was certainly my strong opinion and I
know it's shared by many others that if
the legislature wants this uh task to be
performed then the legislature needs to
it thank you welcome any other
conversation thoughts comments or we all
vote Mr chair I still have some issues
on that page three about the public
being able to uh Source at the source
information on the uh Health
certificates um we we be able to discuss
that at a later time when it comes back
out of Appropriations we certainly would
thank you representative Mason you
raised a point in a private conversation
between you and I and uh I had directed
representative Mason to have a
conversation with Dr Crawford and there
may be a slight verbage change that
needs to occur there for a point that
represent resentative Mason brought up
and that is certainly something that we
could um uh adjust in language when it
is over in finance being looked that I I
discussion all right so we have a motion
202-211 and amendment to House Bill 532
as to pass and I will start FLIR call
the
RO
yes
yes Davis
yes yes keny
yes
s
all right so I will look to Mr
representative Dix for a motion on House
Bill
532 yes I move ought to pass with
202-21 0211 h on uh HB
532 I will second the motion we have a
motion of otpa with a second is there
any further discussion before we go to a
vote
representative um Mr chair we're having
again you hear me now yes
okay thank you
sorry um so so we just added an IT
person um into this an IT position on
top of the original
commission eventually that will occur
again the IT person will be funded
because of the startup cost of initially
they will be funded out of the startup
cost and if they are maintained then
they would have to be a different
correct so I just to give you a little
background I reached out to U uh Dave
alonis who is uh head of the OS and
asked him about the process of updating
the fiscal note because we've made
significant changes to this bill we've
gone from a fee structure to
appropriation I was informed that we're
not able to get an updated fiscal note
until after the house passes the bill on
the floor so if we pass this as a
committee and it goes to the house floor
and then passes before it goes to the
SEC committee then they will do an
updated fiscal but we're not able to do
discussion all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the uh clerk to call the
role on an otpa on House Bill 532 with
Amendment
no
yes Kenedy
yes
yesy
yes yes
yes all right we are not able to put
this bill onto the consent calendar
because of the fiscal note
and so it will have to go to the
house well I want to thank you all
because uh you've been do it a very long
day and especially Long Afternoon three
and a half hours is a long time to sit
and I appreciate your endurance and your
but you know we were elected here to to
the people who listen to their testimony
and I thank you all for doing that
because I think we did a good job of
getting everybody in so just a a quick
question um I didn't catch the final
vote on the otpa and I'm going to need
that for the committee report 16 to
two 162 yes okay so I'll remind
everybody that there a great segue into
my next topic I remind everybody that if
you have been the one that has uh moved
at a a motion that you need to get your
committee report into to me I'd like to
see it by tomorrow if we
could and if you have any questions or
concerns in writing one and need some
help with it certainly reach out I think
most everybody has written in the past
questions all right oh the other
point I'm sorry one quick question we're
emailing them directly to you
correct yes yes that's
fine so a reminder and I'm I'm not sure
if representative Vicks he covered it in
your caucus I did in ours to set aside
the 24 and 25th is session days so just
make sure you get that on your
calendar so um have they told you where
it is I have I know where they're trying
to do it that they're just ironing out
the Last Detail and it will be uh local
to the Manchester area so it won't be a
long
travel thank you yes would you be able
to tell us where where they're trying to
do
it I'm not sure that I'm I I was asking
to Dev at this point so I'm going to
leave it be not that I want yeah I
understand so I'm sorry was that the
24th or 25th of February 24th and 25th
it'll be both
days thank you
certainly anything else before I let you
go all right well listen I appreciate
again all of you in service the state
thank you rest your day yeah excellent
excellent